hello everyone welcome to simply learn
web development is the process of
building a website right from designing
to implementing and to maintaining it it
is considered to be the most innovative
and cost effective way to launch a new
business upgrade existing ones and
attract customers across the globe html
and css forms the basics of front-end
development so
in this tutorial we will cover all the
important concepts related to html and
css so let's move ahead
we'll start with discussing html in 10
minutes then we move forward to discuss
html classes and ids drop down in html
content boxes in html how to create
image slider and navigation bar in html
and how to create html registration form
after grasping all the essential
theoretical concepts we'll design a
full-fledged web page using the concepts
that you learned above we'll go through
some of the important interview
questions in html
and discuss some skills that will help
you become a front-end web developer
we'll end the session with web
development roadmap
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user
then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the ip
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is
so your browser starts by loading the
main html file and then the css and
javascript the user interacts with the
website and is not concerned with the
backend of an application now secondly
we have
the server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's ipaddress which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an ip address
we put a domain name over that ip
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is html
html is the most widely used markup
language for developing and structuring
web pages on the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is css then
now css is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any html element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is
javascript now javascript is a powerful
interpreted language targeted for web
development
it is used for making web pages
interactive and bringing the web pages
to life
so now let's create your first website
now html short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs
div containers tables and more html tags
are nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags so now let's write a simple
html code that will help you understand
the basics of the language
so for this i'm using the text editor
that is visual studio code you can go
ahead and download this text editor from
their official website so here i've
created a simple.html file in my vs code
and i've added the initial html files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction
now this indicates the browser that the
document type to be served to the user
is in fact an html document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your html page
next up you have the html tag that is
used to contain all the web pages html
code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the html tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the html tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
pages title description additional meta
tags and css code so here i've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
html
in 10 minutes
[Music]
all right
you can also add css to the head tag by
using the style tag and change the
display styles of html elements that are
being used
the next section is the body tag now the
body tag contains all the displayable
contents of your web page including
headings paragraphs div containers
tables and more
now the html header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first up let's have a look at them i'm
going to create a simple h1 heading tag
and the message i'm displaying is
this is
the first heading
all right
after this i'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so i'm gonna add a p tag
and save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
br tag
so here let me just add one
for better understanding
now the html div tag defines a division
or a section in an html document that is
used as a container for other html
elements
now these elements can include content
areas sidebars page bars page headers
footers etc
this tag is used to apply styles to html
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the html image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so let's say
img
within which i mentioned the source
[Music]
i'm adding the html logo so let me just
mention that here
and then i'm gonna provide width for it
and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file
and when you look at the browser
you can see that
the first heading is displayed then your
paragraph tag is displayed followed by
the second heading and then the image
now let me show you how you can add
styles for some of these
headings and paragraph tags so here in
back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
and i'm going to change it to career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so i'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when i look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
html tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them on your website in this tutorial
we are going to learn about the classes
and id in the html and how to use them
so
without further ado let's get started so
what is an html class
an html class attribute is used to
specify a single or multiple class names
for an html element
the class name can be used by css and
javascript to do some tasks for html
elements
you can also use this class in a css
with a specific class with a period
character followed by the name of the
class first selecting elements
so let's jump on to the demo to
understand the classes and id better so
we are on our sublime text later
let's add the standard boilerplate of
html
we'll give the title as
classes
and id in html
let's start with the basic example
we'll see how to define an html class
so inside the body tag
we'll add one h1
and we'll give this
class name of
head one
will add some text here this
is
the heading one
now you can copy this part because we'll
need it enough for the lines
so for the h2
this will be the heading 2
for h3
this will be heading 3
and let's add one more h4
this is the heading 4.
so as you can see we have used the same
class name in all our h1 h2 h3 and h4
so if you save the file and
go to the page and refresh
you'll see the headings are there on the
page this is the heading 1 heading 2
heading 3 and heading 4
now let's learn how we can use this
class name for our styling purpose
so we'll open the style tag here
and you will mention the
class name by
period followed by the class name so
head one
open the parenthesis
and let's set the color to
lightsan
and we'll set the font family to set to
it cursive
keep the background color to
black
okay so you can see we have mentioned
the class name dot head head one for
styling purposes and we have given the
color point family and background color
for it so just save the file and go back
refresh
now you can see we have designed this h1
h2 h3 and h4 using our class tag
now let's use another example with a
different class name
so
here only will make the changes let's
name this class as h2 this h3 and let it
be h4
now you can style them separately for
the head to
we can set the color
to say light
pink and we can set the font background
color to
red
okay
now
similarly for the h3
dot
head 3
set the color to
[Music]
i don't know what color this is let's
say fujisa
and set the background color
to
let's say blue
okay save the file and go back to the
page
now you can see we have designed our h1
h2 h3 and h4 using the different class
name
this is the example of using the
multiple classes on the same code
now one thing you should note that these
class may must be separated by the space
there are few points you should know
while working with the class
so the first one will be the class
attribute can be used on any html
element
like any html element can have a class
name the second point will be the class
name is the case sensitive
head one
and
if we change here to say
we keep this h as kept capital so this
will be wrong the style won't be
implemented on the page now if you
refresh
you can see the style is not implemented
so the class names are case sensitive
let's change this back
refresh and now you can see our design
is back
so this was all about html classes
now let's move on to the id attribute
so the html id attribute is used to
specify the unique id for an element of
the html document
it allocates the unique identifier which
is used by the css and the javascript
for performing certain tasks
in cascading stylesheet that is css we
mention an element with a specific id by
using the hash symbol followed by the id
let's work on an example to understand
this better
so we'll use the same previous example
we'll mention the h1 and this time we'll
use the id
so id and we'll name it as head one
this is the first heading
h2 also
will mention the id name as head one
only
head one
this is the
second heading
now to style the heading we'll go back
here
we'll open the style tag
and we'll use the hash symbol to mention
the id so hash
head one open the parenthesis
we'll set the color to
light green
we'll set the font family to cursive
and we'll set the background color
to black
okay
now save the file and go back and
refresh
so you can see this works in a similar
manner to the class apart from it that
we use the hash symbol to mention the id
name
so
now let's change the example and use the
different id names for different h1s
so this can be h1
this can be h2
let's add one more
we'll name it as id
head 3
okay
so
we'll style the
head too
we'll set the color to red
for head tree
we'll set the color to
yellow
let's use green yellow okay
save the file
go back and refresh
now you can see we have the different
style for different ids
so in this way you can use the different
ids
to design your html page in this
tutorial we are going to learn how you
can create a drop down in your navbars
using just html and css so we are on our
sublime text later i have the dot html
and dot css file ready
so let's start by adding the standard
boiler plate
let's give it a title
link your css file to the html file
now inside the body i'll add the ul's
we have added this hash so that when you
click on this home button it won't
redirect you to anywhere
so just save the file
and we'll go back to our page
so you can see we have this home here
okay so let's add some more
so just copy paste this
and we'll name this section about
now inside this about i'll require some
sub menus
so inside this i'll open another ul tag
add sections such as team
clients
career and legacy
and we'll close the li tag here
okay now save the file and go back here
and refresh
now we'll add some more
so
here
we'll add the li for contact
okay so inside this contacts i'll add
the submenus
so
ul
and i'll
copy this code and i'll edit it here
okay so inside the contacts i'll need
email
phone
let's click
twitter
and this will even linkedin
okay
now we'll add some more sections
we'll name the services
and this one will be my news
okay
so this looks fine
a little bit of alignment
yeah
so you can see
we have this home about contact services
and news and inside this we have the sub
menus
okay we forget to
add here
hash inside the specifics
just mention hash
everywhere
okay save the file
go back and refresh okay
so you can see we have this html ready
now let's go back to the css and design
these
drop downs
so first inside our html
select the body tag
we'll add one background image so just
the background looks
more
attractive
so i have an image file saved so i'll
jpg so save
go back
and refresh
yeah you can see we have this black
thing uh we'll shrink this image
so we'll keep the background size to
cover
and we keep the font family to arial
okay
so for the ul tag
we'll keep the margin to zero
we'll keep the padding to zero as well
and we'll set the list style to none
okay now
we'll design the uli part
so we'll keep the float to left
width will set to 200 pixels
we'll set the height to say 40 pixels
um we'll keep the background color
to something darker say
dark blue
dark grey okay
keep the opacity to 0.9
line height particles
keep the text aligned
to center
and font size to
20 pixels
save the file go back and refresh
okay you see we have the background
image in the place we have this snapbar
in the place
and all the dropdowns are here
okay
now it's time to design ul
l i and a
so for this we'll keep the text
decoration to none
color let's keep white
we'll set the display to block
save the file and go back
now we'll add the whole effects for this
drop downs okay
so ul
ally
a dot over
we'll keep the background color
for the over
to say
anything you can circulate select light
caliber
let's see how it looks on the page
refresh
yeah it's look good
now the final part of this requires this
to shrink inside just when you hover
over this so the drop downs will appear
okay
so we'll set this ulli
li 2
display none
and we'll add the hover effect over like
so that when we hover the drop down
appears
save
go back and refresh
now you can see all the dropdowns are
inside
this
when you hover over it and the drop
downs appear
okay
so this is all about the drop downs menu
in html i saw that we can create the
beautiful dropdowns just by using the
html and css nothing fancy
in this video we are going to create the
content boxes which are used in web
pages for various purposes
so let's see an example of what we are
going to create so in this video we are
going to create something
like this this is the content box with
the icon and the description of the
content box
icons here used is from the font
awesome cdn
so let's start creating
so i have my two files open which is
html and css
let's add the standard boiler plate
we'll add the content
boxes in
html
as the title
let's link our css file
now inside the body
let's add a div class container
inside this class container i'll create
another div box
i will require three such boxes so we'll
copy this this three times
on the style sheet
let's set the margin
to zero
and padding also to zero
we'll set the font family
to
sans serif
now
for the container
class
we'll set the position to relative
and we'll set the width to 1200 pixels
which is the whole width of the content
box
we'll set the height
to 300 pixels
and we'll set the margin
to
240 pixels and auto
for the boxes inside the container
will add the position
relative
and will set the width to
let me explain what this is
this css type function is used to
perform a calculation to be used as a
property value
this is specifically used for the width
of the div classes
it requires a mathematical expression
the result will be used as a value
so we'll be using lot of this type
function here in this code
we will set the height to
300 pixels minus 30 pixels
one property of calc function is that it
takes single expression as its parameter
the expression can be any simple
expression combining the following
operators
plus so that is addition minus that is
subtraction multiplication and division
we will set the background
to hash 0 0 0
we'll set it to float left
and we'll specify the margin to 15
pixels
i will set the box sizing to border box
overflow will be hidden
and border radius
let's set it to 10 pixels say
just save the file and let's
go back to the page to see how it
currently looks
so you can see our boxes are in the
proper places we have the background
black with the proper margin between
them
okay so we have the structure
let's
code more
now we need the icon
for that
we will require a icon from the font
awesome
cdn so we'll add the font awesome cdn to
our page
so we'll search
quantosim
cdn 4.7.0
we are using the older version because
it is more stable
so go to this font awesome
libraries
here select the version and copy the
link tag
go back to the page and add it here
delete this integrity part
now here inside this class box
add one div which will be named class
icon
and inside here we'll add the link of
the icon so search here
font awesome icon 4.7
go to the first one
here you can search the any icon you
want uh let me search for
say
information
so i'll go to the information
and i'll copy this
go back to the code and add it
here now inside this i'll create another
div which will be for use for content
so we'll name it class content
and inside this i'll add one h3
info
and inside it
i'll add some
text
uh
copy this much from here
to there
now delete this whole part
and put it inside
p tag
so inside the p tag
add them
yeah
so
let's go back to the file and see how it
looks right now
okay so you cannot see the icon here
because it is black let's try to change
the color here
so that you can see the icon
so let's set it to ff0
okay so you can see i have the icon in
place this is and this is the text that
we have added to this content box
now let's style this content box first
set it back to 00.
[Music]
dot icon
we'll set the position to absolute
set the top
to zero
left to zero and we'll set the width to
100
we'll set the height also to 100 percent
background will be hash f00
i will set the transition
to 0.5 seconds
we'll keep the z index as one so that
the icon will be visible
okay
refresh
yeah you can see the icon here
okay
now let's add the hover effect on that
so container
dot
box dot
over
icon
we'll set the
top to 20 pixels
calculate the left two
50
minus 40 pixels
with
80 pixels
i keep it 280 pixels as well
and let's set the border radius
to 50
okay
so now that we have or
repeat
so now that we have added the hover
effect let's save and go back to the
page
now let's
design the icon so container dot
box dot icon
dot fa
also set the position to absolute
top will be 50 percent
left 50 percent
transform let's translate it to
minus fifty percent
minus fifty percent
and keep the font size to
80 pixels
transition 0.5 seconds
and we'll set the color to
save the file and let's go back to the
page
yeah
so you can see our icon has now
bigger size and with the hover effect it
shrinks for text to visible
now we need to add the hover effect to
the icon so that the font size increases
for that we'll add container
box dot over
we'll keep the font size too
40 pixels
okay
now it's time to design the content
inside the container box so we'll set
container
dot box
dot content
all the positions are absolute
will set the top 200 percent
so that when the icon shrinks the whole
text will visible to the text box
we will set the height
to will calculate it
hundred percent
minus hundred pixels
text align center
keep the padding 20 pixels
for proper spacing
box sizing as border box
transition to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the opacity
to zero
okay save the file and let's go back
yeah
and you can see the icons are in the
center of the shrinking circle
now let's add the hover effect
now when you set the opacity to one
another text
okay we are not
design yet h3np so let's start designing
it
so container
dot box
dot content h3
in pixels
keep the padding to zero
color
and let's give the font size to 24
pixels
now you will see the text will be
visible inside the box
so refresh
you can see this is the heading of our
like this content box
now similarly let's style the paragraph
tag
so container
dot box
dot content
p
margin will be zero
padding will be also zero
and color will be fff as usual
yup we are almost there
now we will design these two boxes
with some spacing and effects over here
now
inside this
delete them will copy paste the above
code here
so copy from here dip class container
we'll change the icon classes here
so for this let's keep search as
a
rch instead of copying the class by
going back to the font cd we can
directly add the class search here if
you know the name of the class
and here we can add
location
so the class name for location is map
marker
save the file
and let's go back
yeah
now you can see
these things are here
with the good content box when you hover
over this box the
this whole thing shrinks and you can see
the text visible
now add we'll add some styles we'll
change the color and we'll add one
background here so that when this
shrinks the background color of the
black changes
okay
so we'll go back to our code
so to change the color of the box
we'll hand here dot container
dot
box
and we'll use the nth child property and
child
one because the first box dot icon
so we will keep its background to
pink
okay
and dot container
box and child
one
its color will be when it shrinks let's
keep it to orange
yeah
so save the file
go back
and refresh
okay so you can see we have the icons in
places and when you go
click on here so the hover effect
shrinks this and this is the pink in
color we have the background orange with
some text here
you can see
smooth transitions
so this is all for the content boxes in
html you can use different icons here
using this font at awesome icon there
are several icons here you can use any
of them
and just make sure that the padding and
the text are aligned in the proper
places in this video we learn how we can
create a beautiful html slider by using
just html and css a little bit of
javascript
our image slider moves something like
this
we have the background image and this
images that i have taken
for example purpose we have these radio
buttons and we click on the radio
buttons
we can go through our images one by one
also the images will change
automatically after sometimes as you can
see so let's see how we can create this
image slider
so here in the desktop i have created
one file where i have the required
images
and html and css file
so first in the experience style let's
add our radio buttons
so we'll create one div
and limit to this class slider
and start this i'll create another
which will be named as bim class slice
inside this book flashlight will add the
radio buttons
so input
the input type will be radio
and let's give this name
radio button
and we'll tag them with id radio one
so as you can see
we need four buttons here so we'll add
four radio buttons here
so just copy paste this four times
here change the id to radio 2 radio 3
and radio 4 so we can distinguish
between the four radio buttons
so after the creating the filter buttons
will add our required images so we'll
create android div and limit class
slide first
inside i'll create an image tag
and specify the path of the image
in a similar way we create a
four div tags for four images
so just
we'll do
another div with class name
slide
inside this image
2.jpg
you
so just save the file and let's reach
our code
we have the review buttons we have the
images so let's just go back to our file
and see how it looks
so if we refresh
we see we have the four radio buttons
here and some distorted images
so let's just fix this images in the css
so inside of css style
we'll add the body
and we'll set the margin to receive
pixels
padding to zero
we'll set the height to say under
vertical height
we'll set the display to flip
uh we'll justify the content to center
we'll set the align items to center
and we'll set the background to black
so just
refresh this file
so we still need to fix these images
so just
set the slider width to
800 pixels
there's an error we'll set this width
we'll set the height
to 500 pixels
then set the border radius
to 10 pixels
and overflow will keep as hidden
for the slice part
we'll set the width to 500 percent
high to 500 pixels
and display to select
so let's save the file and see how it
looks on the page
so yeah you can see the images now in a
proper size you have to click this radio
button we have the background black
so let's fix this hints
so for the slides input
okay before styling this let's add some
more html content here
so after adding the image we have to
create the automatic navigation button
and the manual navigation button
so after this
add another div
the class name
navigation auto let's see
and inside this navigation auto will add
div
truss
auto button one
we need the full button so we'll copy it
four times
and this will be
my button two
this is the button 3 and this is
outside this
will create another div
just go for the manual navigation button
so we'll name this
navigation
make sure it's politic navi
navigation
manual
and inside this
bow we'll add our radio buttons usually
manually
we'll name it class
manual button
we need the core button so we'll copy it
four times
change the label to radio 2
radio 3 and radio 4
so i think this will work enough so here
we have the navigation
okay we have a spell mistake here
class and navigation kind of existed
classes
so let's recheck our code
it's a good
your pattern so that you don't encounter
any error so okay we have a different
slider here
and inside that class adder we have the
four radio button one two three pro
we have added our images
inside the div tags with the name slide
okay
we have created a navigation order
the four buttons and navigation manuals
are the four buttons okay
so let's save the file and go back and
refresh it and see how it looks
okay
we have to add some css here
so inside the slides
input
before the display was done
for the dot foreign
now we'll
add this type of image
we'll set the width to 800 pixels
and we'll set the height to say 500
pixels
okay
so let's save the file and let's go back
to see how it looks right now
okay so you can see the images are
properly aligned here
we have to style our radio buttons for
here so let's go back to our css
now the code we are going to write
navigation
so just add here comment manual slide
navigation
navigation manual
will set the position to absolute
then set the width to 800 pixels
will not have the height here will set
the margin
so the margin top will be
minus 40 pixels
this we will keep it as left
and the justify content
will be sent out
so let's go here and
go back to the page see how it looks
right now
okay the images are in the center you
can see
now we cannot see the regular buttons
just as now we have to add some color to
it so that the radio buttons will be
visible
so go back to the css
we'll add the manual button
we'll set the border
to
shape three pixels
solid and red
you can take any color you want
i will set the padding to five pixels
uh we'll set the border radius to
say nine pixels
we set the processor to point pointer so
that when
buttons the cursor look as a pointer
and we'll set the transaction to one
second
save
go back and refresh
so now you can see the buttons are here
not properly spaced but yeah they're
here
so let's add the spacing and everything
else
so we will set the manual button
we'll set the margin
right to 40 pixels
and it's time to add the over effect so
for the manual
button
now where will we um say
background
the color
blue
so just save the file and go back and
refresh
yeah so you can see our manual buttons
are in place
when you hover over it you can see the
blue type and when you click
nothing happens right now because we
don't have any javascript in response to
this later button
we'll add them in the end
first let's design these buttons so this
is for the manual button
now we'll add one code which will be
used when you want to save the reader
button by default
so let's understand how those video
buttons work in this file so the radio
version is used where two or more
options are identified which are
mutually exclusive and the user has to
do exactly one choice
in other words click on a non-selected
radio button will erase any other button
that is selected on the list previously
derivatives include lower cognitive
layers as they permanently keep all the
options visible such that users can
easily analyze them radio buttons are
also simple to use for users who have
difficulty making effective mass
movements
so we'll add hash radio
dot check
so the sign that we have added here is
more sibling combinator
it combines two sequence of simple
selectors having the same parent and the
second must come immediately after the
first
so
we'll add dot first
and for this we set the margin left
to zero
okay so this will be radio one
the label that we are added in our
manual buttons
we will need four such
buttons so we'll copy this four times
one two three and four
this will be my for radio button two
and we'll set the margin left here to
minus 20 pixels
for radio button g then set it to say
minus 40 pixels
i'm going to forget to add
pixelation
and for the last button
we'll set it to minus 60 pixels
so all this code is for the manual
navigation button now let's design for
automatic navigation button
so
we open dot navigation
we'll set the position to absolute
then set the display to flat
we will set the width
to 800 pixels
let's just define the content of the
center
and inspect the margin top
to save for 60 pixels
let's set 460 pixels
now
so i'll add this tag to navigation auto
so
navigation content
then set the border
solid red
make sure you keep this sequences solid
and same in both the navigation auto and
navigation manual because if you change
the color here you will see the two
manual buttons there so
for
this example let's change this to green
so when you save and go back
and refresh
yeah
but you can see the two buttons there
this is a green and this is red so if
there are two colors the
buttons will overlap will not look good
so we'll just keep it here red
we'll set the padding to 5 pixels
we'll set the border radius to 9 pixels
and we'll set the transition to 1
seconds
now same code as here which i have added
for
checking out the radio buttons
so we'll just copy this whole code
and paste it here
i'll have to tweak some
things here
so the class was navigation dot auto
so we'll add here
navigation auto
dot
auto button one
we'll filter some background
so we'll delete this code
background let's say
any color
pink
delete this whole thing
and just change the radio button here
this will be radio button
this will be three
and this will be phone
now we have all the designing place
now we have already designing this let's
go back to the code and refresh
so now you'll see everything is in place
the background is black the images is
properly aligned we have this button so
let's click
so when you click you see the images
slides this is the photo match
third
second
and first so
your beautiful image slider is ready
all right now is left is to add the
javascript code to this image directory
function in automatic manner
so now we'll go back to this html5
and below this div tag
will open one script tab
and inside the script tag
we create one
variable named counter
we'll set it to one
open recreation function set interval
so what this part specifically does
one is named counter and it will check
against the id that we have created in
radio then the radio button is
checked and it encounters
the counter will be plus plus that
control increase by one
so after the counter has reached the
floor
so it will get back to the starting
point that is one
so
the whole point of this code is to
make the images slide in you know
so just save
and go back
now when you refresh
you will see the images will move after
sometimes
specifically two seconds
now when the images reach the last stage
it goes back to the first
you can also change it by clicking here
manually
when we talk about achievement based
development so in html based development
navigation is very important where you
have multiple pages attached to so that
when you click on this page or click on
any hyperlink it will take you to the
new page now so that you can move back
and forth so this navigation is very
essential part of any web development so
that you can offer the navigation so
this
simple application of html they would
like to start from scratch so let's go
and create a new folder now and give the
name called navigation
and inside this navigation we want to
create some new pages
so
here i'm going to create index
dot html
the css name would be
app.css and along with this we would
like to also create some new folder
inside this i'll keep all the navigation
files inside this so i can save pages
inside this pages let me have total
number of three pages with me one is
called about
dot html
then we create
contact dot html
then we create one more that is called
services.html
dot html
so these three links we will create it
one by one but first let's start with
the index.html
so what's there in my index.html file
so
first thing i would like to start with
my same html syntax
here
well
this is my basic construct
so i will start with my
link real from here so that i can have
my style shape with me
link are you looking to style shade href
equal to app
it says though i have not written
anything but i just left it as a blank
in my body tag i would start with the
navigation so html5
brought you some new tags known as call
a nav tag which is once again
won't change anything drastically in
your browser however they are called
sementex which will help you for the
seo that stand for search engine
optimization so i'll start with my nav
inside my nav i will start with my div
div
i'll say navigation bar so but before
that i say
class equal to
heading there is my dev tag
and inside my tip tag i want to bring my
heading so i say h4
and i said
navigation bar
and after the div tag i will start with
my url tag which is an unordered list
inside my
unordered list i can set li that stand
for list items
and i can offer log many links inside
this so you will i just offer the class
equal to
nav hyphen
links
and inside this my li tag i say
a which is a anchor tag
so
a link href equal to
now here i offer
the name i say index
dot html
and that's it and this will be by
default active so we say
class equal to
active
a
class equal to it
active and http index.html file and here
we offer home
for home page
i'll copy this line
and paste it for other three urls
so
here
the
active won't be there
instead we say hrf equal to
the location called pages
under this pages
we say about
about.html and here we say about
okay copy this
paste it
and all of this about we always say
services.html
and here we say
services
inside this we offer contact
contact
okay
and once the nav tag is over
i will offer the div
just give the name body hyphen
text
i just say
h1 tag inside this
and this is the home page
that's it so that's my home page which
is ready with me
and along with this whichever the other
pages are also available
those pages i also want to use
so first of all let me check how this
page looks like it
well it looks like a pretty basic page
so once this page is ready
what i will do is
here
i copy the content
and paste it here and above and let's
see what's there in my above see few
things will change
number one here
this app.uses
now here we have to just use
dot dot
there's an app.uses for me
so
we have to offer some title too so after
this linkarion
you often
title this title i can say
about
okay
so rest everything is fine
so h4 navigation bar nav links here
i have to offer the links for my base
html page
so
when i talk about index.html file
okay it won't come so
index.html5
so i won't say it is an active anymore
just remove this
line class equal to it it's just a
normal h
but about would be active in this case
so
a
class equal to
editor of this
services
contact
is as usual saying but i would not be
having any
pages anymore
because we are in the same location
that's why
and here i say this is a
about this is about page
about bridge
so
that's it
i'll go back and check
if it all fine
home is active right now
about you can see it as an about page
right now
the word page is just appear as it is
saying
contents are more or less looks like and
same that is why you are able to see
now
just like that
just go back and copy the others
now here
up css navigation bar active
it is in contact so make contact as an
actor
so text html file remains same this is
contact page
so
that's how it is
and uh we will say about my
other properties which is my
services
copy sorry
copy this contact
and here
i'll be activating my
service in this case
so
class equal to active i remove it from
here
make it available here this is
service page navigation index page is
about active yeah or looks good heading
about okay here i change
service
there's a change to
content so looks fine
let's see
okay
service contact
about
so for about we need to check where we
need to go
so we have got pages
about.html pages also there
so
all there so we would like to see
how the about page will be activated
here so index.html file also contains an
about
so here
when i
refresh
[Music]
page now services
so like this
it is happening for you
okay so
that's how exactly my thing is
so
we're all good
and
services contact
home all good
well my page is now ready and going
forward we would like to beautify my
pages by offering the css well let's get
started with our css file
so in my css file i will start with my
common properties
which is margin
i'm saying 0 pixel
followed by padding
i'm making this a zero pixel again
again we want box sizing
thus i say border
iphone box
okay
well going forward this is my standard
settings for all different type of
properties now i want the other
properties to be get introduced that is
called box body text
dot
body
hyphen
text
inside this body text i said display
flex
now when i see where the body text is
available go to my text.html file
body text is available here dev class
so here in my css file i can say body
text display reflex
i say font family
font family i can give anything
it is given called mod
share it
these two
we are offering it
later on align items
item center
followed by justify content
and making it center
then margin top
250 pixels
these are the properties are there
followed by
okay first let's check what is an effect
here
see
it looks better now
now we would like to go ahead with the
nav
i already have this nerve with me
now
display
flex
then justify content
space around
followed by
align item
align items i want to make center
and then we want to say min height
so
we say min
hyphen
okay so min height we are giving 8vh
followed by background color
just set d
same color
and uh same font family i just copy this
form timely and make it available here
well let's check
there we go so navbar looks awesome but
i still feel the links needs to be
justified we want to make it even more
better but before that i offer the
nav links so here
i say
nav links so dot nav
hyphen links
this nav links will have display
flex
display
flex
and then justify content
that i want to make it space around
again
followed by width
so
[Music]
width
so width would be 30 percent
perfect and now
nav link li dot
nav links
li
this
list
style none
let's see how it is changing
there we go that it looks really nice
so nav links are ready and
i want to make it a heading
heading i want to make it more organized
so let's see about a heading
so here i say dot
heading
and inside this heading i say color
which is white
followed by text
transform
text text transform upper case
followed by letter spacing
this letter spacing will be 5 pixels
and followed by large font size
and this font size is just 20 pixel
that's it and let's see what is
different here
here awesome so this navigation bar is
now looking great
and it is giving me all the basic
operation whichever we have expected now
this nav links whichever we have created
okay they are working fine but i just
want to make it even more beautiful
and how i can make it more beautiful to
make it i would like to go ahead with
the nav links again
dot
nav links
of type anchor tag
now i would like to activate my anchor
tag by making it color
white
okay followed by text decoration
text decoration
and followed by letter spacing
let us pressing three pixels
and then
font fit
font weight bolt
and font size
14 pixels
and padding
14 pixels
and 16 pixels
both options
that's it and uh
followed by we want to use the nav links
when i will hover it so the color should
change so we are saying dot
nav links
and here with li
followed by a dot
active when the anchor tag is active
then in that case i want to change the
background color
to
lights light c green i can say
lights
so
[Music]
we have this option called light c green
this one right that looks beautiful
and followed by say
i copy this
and this active
so nav links like dot active
background color we are using but if it
is not active then in that case what you
will use
so
i can just change the small thing
here
i have changed this color
uh now let me try to copy this first
i tell you about what i want to copy
this and paste it as usual here what i
see is when it is an active
okay when it is an active i will change
the color to
i think the spelling is wrong
active it should be
active
background color i want to change it to
green so for that we are just using the
color
hash
this is a green color
where it is inactive and when this is
not active
so we can just say a colon
active
which you've used now now li colon
active or we can say equal over
equal
over
a colon
over and here we say colon
not
dot
active
that's it
let's see how it works
awesome this looks beautiful home home
is active right now you say it is on a
home page i can see it is an about page
it is service page it is a contact now
you can see it looks even more
awesome in this html piece hands-on we
are expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of html as well
as the css so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how html and css can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're going gonna offer
you that is related to your html
registration page okay so
as you know for this particular
registration development application i
would like to use the visual studio code
which is one of the very very popular
tool provided by microsoft
so this tool will be using it for our
mini application development so let's
get started with this
so step number one let me go back and
create a new folder now i'm going to
create a new folder name called
registration
and
inside this i would require two files
number one it's called index.html
another one that is called
css we can say
f dot
css so in index.html file
we want
some standard development so i want to
start with my html tag
so
i already have this html base autofill
code provided by your visual studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic
structure for this html which you can
have the html tag head tag
as well as the body tag and from this
point onwards we will start developing
our code now so
i want to develop a registration page so
in this registration page i will start
from my
form tag now so inside this form it is
saying like form action to something i
really do not have any backend so i just
leave it as a blank and here i will
start with my h1 tag where i want to say
register
after this register i want to offer the
paragraph tag where i can say please
fill
in this
form
to
register with us
register
with
us
okay
now after that i would like to start
with horizontal row
so hr
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level
in this level for
i just want to give the name called fm
it's just the name
and after this fn stands for the first
name
and within this level i would like to
use the b tag which is
i would say that bold
here i will pass first name
bold tag is closed it's a label
inside this label i would like to use
input tag
here i will call input equal to text
and offer a few other details also like
i say
a placeholder
placeholder will offer you what to give
i'll say first name
that is
the placeholder value after this name
equal to
fn that is a stand for first name
after that id
id is option
but if you want to pass we will use this
id fn
id equal to fn
and
required
because i want this field cannot be
black
so this is my
first text box where i have this
first name with me
like that i will go ahead and talk about
my
next property or password and for
password also i would like to have the
similar details with me
so this level i'll copy
and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we're giving the name
called psw
here we are saying password
and
input type in your text so here i will
change input applicable to password
because password field
details would not be visible to you
please
here we say
placeholder i can say enter
password
name equal to
you can give psw
id equal to we can give same psw
so
we have a password in a similar line we
would like to offer the confirm password
fields too
i will copy this line
and paste it again and here we can say
confirm password
you can say
cpsw
again password enter
confirm password cpsw
and cpsw
now it's over
after this we want to make it as a
horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
so here is the button we can say
register
and here in my button
i would like to offer the type equal to
submit
are we going to
submit
so that's it so this is
the simplest form i have it
now i would like to see how it really
looks like it
so from here i would like to open it
revealing finder
let's open this
well it looks like that
fine so this is what makes formulas form
is ready and now we would like to go
back and start developing my css in
which i would beautify my form to offer
some more details of this well friends
as we know the html page is ready it's
time to go back and start developing a
css to beautify my html so inside the
css i would like to start with the tag
which is a call body
and
inside this body tag i can offer some
basic setups but
i just want to give the basic background
color now which is called
background hyphen color
i can just give the name called deal
that's a background color let's
the rest of the things i can just leave
it as it is now for all the other
properties i can say box sizing
border iphone box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits
now first thing you need to understand
which other places i will be using the
container so you see here in my
index.html file
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say h1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
div
class equal to
container okay
and this particular div tag will get
closed only at the last
so
this tip tag
will close at the last
here
so i want to make
the look and feel for this complete
container
in much more better way so here in my
container we want to say
margin auto
let's press enter here
margin
auto
now with
50
then adding
16 pixel
followed by background color
which we want white
then box shadow
this box shadow we want to give some all
four origins 20 pixels
continuation to same 20 pixel
and zero pixel
and which color we want so i just say
rgba
in this rgb you just give the value
point zero
again
zero
again 0
and
the value which you want to give to this
alpha because it
is always between 0 2 1 we are saying
0.7 that is an opacity
well four properties is given
now let's see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a css
in my html so let's add the css so
inside my
browser html
now inside my head
we add link
link rl equal to style sheet href equal
to
app.css
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now
so this is your container okay which you
can see it is having some shadow i would
like to organize this all set up text
boxes in much more better way
so
after this
we want to offer the other properties to
liken for my input
go back to my css
so after this container we want input
input again
type equal to
text
now
also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is 100
after
sorry
then padding
once again 15 pixels
then margin
we are offering 5 pixels
0
22 pixel
0
followed by display
display i will say
inline block
in light block
followed by border do you want any
border
so i say null
border none and background
we can offer the color so we can say
white smoke
that's it let's see in my html
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized
so this is
your form but i want to make it even
more better now because i want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the
beautification needs to be added more
here
we want to offer the same input type
text input type password i copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
focus
this has to be your focus
focus and here also on focus
now background color
we want to change to anything but for a
typing we can just give
same
and
outline
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button so
here we see dot
i do not have that class for register
button so i have to create this class
inside my
button
register btl
i would like to offer the properties for
those like background color
t
followed by color
which is
white
then
padding we offer 16 pixel
then border
no
then cursor
i think it is better to have pointer
only
then width
100
solve by margin
this auto
then opacity
then i say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
button
let's see
wow this looks better now
so this is a full size button
so this is for my button
and i want the moment i take my cursor
on button
the color should change or it should
look like an hover
copy this
over
and here we say opacity
which is with the valuable one
that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working when i press on
register you see the messages
please filter field blank and it is
changing
the
when we talk about the situation called
focus so in this it works like that when
i give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so this time we gonna
develop another very interesting example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so
what we will do is start creating a new
folder now first of all i'm going to
give the name called
html
quiz
now i'm going to create a three files
inside this number one i'm going to say
index.html
index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first so we'll go
to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards div tag
so within my tip tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class to this
particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we say
the class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set there
id
equal to
question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
this div and we say class
equal to height
now within this step tag we would like
to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tip tag here
and this step id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we are just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer one
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tip tag is getting closed here and now
here
before the last step tag is getting
closed we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to
controls that's another tip tag so under
this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start hyphen btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
ptn
space
btm
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next hyphen button
btn and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
type tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that the div tag is getting closed
and
that's it
and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this drive tag i would like to close
even before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip tag which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
the script
src equal to
script.js
that's it so our html page is almost
ready
let's review
and uh
yes i can see some standard buttons has
been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
button cell
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
q
again
hyphen rom
this value we're giving is
zero
then we are saying hyphen iphone here
hyphen
correct
145
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyper hyphen hue
thus we are making with the variable
hyphen f1u
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero
after that display
none
after that not display i would say none
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we're providing width almost 100
followed by height
height we are providing is called once
again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contents i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
hyphen hyphen q
and followed by
100
comma
20
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
refine the styles we always use
link
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we're providing
queue
var
and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just for
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than correct
we're using
rock
well
these two properties we have defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80 percent
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
radius that we are providing 5 pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow we can say 0
0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid
this button grid we would like to start
from here
btn grid beating grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns so here we are saying
repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be there 20 pixels
and then
0. this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
i can open here
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
were
hyphen iphone u followed by
100
30
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
100
and 50
percent
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding
just
5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which you want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button over
dot
ptn dot
or
whole
and for this performer
you want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for dot
next hyphen pt
common look and feel for both
font size
one
dot five
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is be like 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls we say display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start then only the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const and here we will
say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name called
start
hyphen btn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name and give the
name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen
container like this we would like to use
one more
and that is called question element
question
element documented good element by id
here we'll be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shovel question because we
want every time the questions to be get
shuffled
shuffled questions
shuffle questions
current question
index
shuffle quotients and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
questions
equal to
eric
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay so i would like to have answers for
sure so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping its
core false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who is the prime minister of india
so we can have two ounce answers
available
okay
talk about kundalindra modi value is
called work true
second we're gonna give the name call
which value is called false so taken the
values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like
here next equal what is 4 x 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called 6
which is false seconds 12
like that total we have created
3
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be the
function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
player
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element dot class list dot remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
called what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached there
is only one function we've attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
called
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by using if
correct
then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
but we'll try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your
select answer so you have to basically
select the answer so this is a little
bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot data set dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in this set status class we'll be
passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers button element
dot
children
okay followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set
dot
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called f
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current quotient index
plus 1
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list dot
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we will be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these other functions are used right
now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is
something which we wanted to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text
equal to
question
dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each
and here i would like to use
your passing word
answer as a parameter
now here we like to create a button
called const
button equal to
document or
get sorry document.create element
like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot
add here we are
offering
btn
okay now you're saying
if
the condition is
answer dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
dataset
dot
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state
the function we are calling it and
saying
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is what the sect
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start function
start
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five
we're passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are given zero right
now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
dot
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready next thing which you to start the
cover button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in
this on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
is automatically making rest of them as
a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
narendra modi
great next
and i say
for multiply by 3a12 i said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask is a flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine and it gives me the
restart now
and that's it so this is how
dear friends your project is now
completely working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button that is giving me four multiply
by three that means it is one second
have taken
random question this mini project will
help you to understand how we can align
our content to display to my end user so
not many things are there we have got
css in place we have a html in place and
using some css3 based effects using some
html5 based effects we will be creating
our mini website having some single html
page and
a css and lot of images will help you to
understand in case if i want to develop
a website how to kick start them
okay so let's get started so this is my
folder i've created call web pro and in
a similar folder i'll be creating some
of the files so my first file will be
called styles
dot
css
so in this style start series first of
all i need to import some of the fonts
which i will be using it throughout my
development so i'm saying to add it
import url
and here i'll be offering the location
by saying
https
songs
dot
google
apis
dot com
okay google please dot com slash
css
okay question mark we have to use family
equal to here we can use alure
allura and with using this pipe symbol
we're using joe's friend
joe's film
plus
sense
so that is the url for me in case if you
want to verify whether this url does
exist or not so what you can do you can
just copy this
and go to your browser
and uh
try to paste this and check if it does
exist yes it does exist that means these
urls are available to us so this is a
url which i'll be using it
for my development after that i'll be
using this asterisk
and providing some of the core features
like a margin
colon 0
followed by
other details okay like i'm saying
margin colon 0n
adding once again 0
followed by box sizing
this we're saying bottle box
followed by outline
okay none
okay
and
post this will be offering less the
style
here we are also saying none
after that text decoration
text decoration once again
none
after that font family
font family so we are using this
this option which you are saying called
joe's fill
okay
sends the bar which you have used
comma
you're using one more called sense
hyphen sorry
so this would be a first
set of the style which will be global to
all i'll be using this
well earlier we have given the common
style to all now i'll be giving a style
to my paragraphs
so
here in my paragraph we are trying to
save margin
hyphen
and bottom i want to give all 15 pixels
because i want to develop all the styles
well in advance before i proceed ahead
we are saying font icon size
yeah font icon size that we want to give
it for 14 pixels
followed by line height
line height i'll grab 20 pixels
after that color
color you can give anything
okay so there's one very common color
called light blue
for that there's one value called
five
f
okay
8e 8
e
and again 8
e
you can see that is called a kind of
light green color which is coming up now
okay which is used now a part of this
paragraph will be using h1 title
okay as shown title and in this h1 title
we are saying margin bottom
margin bottom we are saying 20 pixels
after that color
orange
okay
record semicolon here along with this
font family
this one family we're giving a loader
okay
along with this we also want to give
curiosity
cursor
okay also text
transform
this text transform i want to use
uppercase
along with this font size
this font size i would like to give 38
pixels
followed by font size
yeah so this font size i want to give is
called 30 pixels
or font size you've already given a word
spacing we have to give
this word spacing was given 25 pixels
followed by letter spacing
uh let us specify 5 pixels
so these are the details we have given
for the
h1 title
it's okay so now we'll be talking about
our buttons
which are the look and feel we have to
go or provide to our button so we are
saying once again
dot btn
okay space a means under my button tag a
what i want so i say
width
180 pixels
once again
yeah alright 180 pixels we're giving
height
35 pixels
followed by line height
line height we're giving 35 pixels
followed by border
this bottle will be 2 pixels
solid
black
okay after that color
color we want to give it i would say red
would be
sufficient enough
followed by display
display i want to give it a score block
followed by margin
margin i want to give 25 pixels
auto
and zero
followed by texture line
okay
center
so this is for btn a which we have given
along with this btn a there are some
other properties are also available i
can dot
main underscore
container
here we would like to provide position
okay colon
relative
okay
after this position we would like to
also provide the property for navbar
so we are saying
navbar
underscore or let's talk about navbar
rest of the stats will be offering it a
little later
with the snapbar we are providing this
with
okay this width will be a hundred
percent
okay this would be a 100
and also we provide height
this height will be 65 pixels
okay provided by position
position we are providing absolute
after that we are setting display
display we are providing flicks
after that we are saying justify content
justify contents we are saying space
around
after that we are saying align items
this we are getting
a center
okay along with this we are giving this
logo
of type a
so inside this logo we are saying font
family
this form firmly we are once again using
the same
the one which you have used earlier
you remember alura and curiosity let me
we can use the same
whatever we have used it earlier
so
same condition you can use it here
so we remember earlier what we have used
in my previous program
okay font family so the same font family
i would like to use it here also
okay so logo a but let me check
somewhere down the line
what wait
font family so let me copy the same
and paste here right now
okay so we have a god
family with me
which we have taken it right now to my
existing logo a along with i want to use
for
font size
we would like to use 32 pixels
also color
and as usual i would like to use red
okay
so that is for logo on which we have
basically applied this
a part of this we would like to also use
for navbar
mapper
underscore
item
space ul
and here we would like to provide margin
0
and padding
again zero
followed by line style
list style sorry
list
style here we are saying none see that
is the benefit of having this visual
studio code because sometimes when
you're going wrong it immediately
gives you the idea of like saying like
hey you're going somewhere wrong that's
what the suggestions were not given to
us
so till here we've added furthermore
we'll be adding few more styles into my
code
well
never
tell you what we have seen now followed
by saying
dot navbar
okay underscore
items
followed by
legal which we have it and along with
this we would like to go ahead with this
list items also
and in this list items we need
few details first i talk about call
float
so float left for sure then we talk
about curve width
width will be 100 pixels
and now we talk about color height
height will be 40 pixels
well
float width height we have talked about
now we talk about background color
background color we can say light salmon
that looks nice
and opacity
opacity we can just give 0.8
followed by line height
line height i can give called 40 pixels
okay along with this we also want
texture line
once again
center
okay this is for
these items
now under the same nav bar you may have
some other properties also
okay this is for navbar uli and we can
also have the same property
copy
but along with this li i can also have
this anchor tag we can select multiple
elements together
so here i would like to offer text
transform
you see this text transform
uppercase
followed by color
this color we are saying black
and we are talking about called text
decoration
text decoration we want nothing
along with this i want display
and as usual it will be a block type
okay that was li and within this anchor
tag i also can have a hover
let me copy the same
and with this anchor i can have the
property name call what
cobalt
so what property you are expecting for
this
so here in my hover property i can say
background color
and i can use
tomato
okay
well after this in the same name bar
items
i also want to have
after the anchor tag
what should happen so this conditions i
want to utilize because i want to offer
some of the animations behavior
right over there so what animations i
would like to go ahead that i need to
offer under this navigation items ally
so i just copy this
paste it below but this over which we
are talking about we would like to
change from
to after
okay
after
so i'm removing this background color
with this because background color can
be changed to something else
so i can change to white
right
well
let me have few more properties to be
get added
first thing we are trying to secure
position
position will be absolute
okay we want from left side
left i want to give fifty percent space
after this from bottom
i'm saying zero
okay
now i want to talk about transform you
remember to the property available in
css
and here we are saying
translate
x and in say this translate x i say
minus 50
okay and here we are saying after that
scale
x
okay and here we're providing what zero
so that's what the condition we want to
provide it for the transform
and the next thing will be transform
origin
transform origin so i say 50
and again
15
after this we would like to talk about
width
width will be 100
percent okay and we also want this
height
height will be two pixels
okay with hundred percent height to
pixels
after that we talk about transition
in this transition we can talk about
chord transform
okay transform to 50
ms
okay so these are so far the details
which are available with us
which i would like to use it in my code
okay that is for after of this anchor
tag
so when we talk about horror you further
want to change the behavior over there
so in this case i would like to use the
same
condition i just copy that
and here
when me say colon
so you can see
ally
space
a colon over
colon after
so what conditions you want to use it
here so
transform
okay so here
translate x
okay so here you say minus
50
scale x
1.0
followed by we would like to use again
dot
navbar
okay underscore item
okay ul
followed by li
followed by once again ul
once again li
and here in this case we want to offer
display now
display
none
okay
so
that's okay and one more conditions i
would like to take it here is
here when i say uli li colon hover so i
can say ally
colon
over uli so we will say display
block
that's the condition
okay so so far we have written this much
of css we would like to go ahead and try
to implement some of the html behavior
and be back to our css to make this
possible
okay everyone so we have developed a lot
about css it's time for us to move
towards our next
ui that is called the html part okay so
here
i've already kept it just for the kind
information i've just downloaded few of
the
images
okay from the internet just to utilize
into my application
i'm gonna create
the another
and give the name called index.html
okay this index.html file let me have
this template with me okay so i have got
template with me
now here
we want to use some of the
awesome css styles for of my usual
development
so within my head tag we would like to
use this link
this is for csf so say link real equal
to stylesheet
and href equal to now i'm going to give
the location so this css anyways is
there there's equal style we want to say
called styles.css
and one more style i would like to use
in my code
but the location will be somewhere else
i'm saying
https cdnjs
dot
cloud flare
dot com slash
ajax slash libs
slash font
hyphen
awesome
okay that is a well-known style sheet we
are giving the version called 5.15
dot one slash
css
slash all
sorry
on dot
min
dot
css so that is the location actually
okay now i want to just check but this
location does exist or not so i'll just
copy this
paste it in my browser to verify
well yes this
style does exist so
we would like to go ahead and continue
well i would like to give some title in
case if i want so this is a document i
can just get the name called
website
okay just keep this look capital website
development
coming to my body tag
here i just want to give a
dive class equal to
let's give the name called main
underscore
container
okay and also we want to give id
equal to
oh
that is a div tag for that
okay
now along with this i want to give some
other type of div tags to where i want
to use it now here within this div tag i
want to give another div tag where i
want to provide the navbar so
do
equal to navbar
okay and within this nav bar i want to
use another div tag
which says
class
equal to
logo
okay
within this div tag we want to provide
the hlf
okay a href equal to
here we want to provide this hash
okay and this will be provided to
home so this is we have a got dev class
we have a quality of class equal to logo
and under this we are providing this
hashtag and using
simply run
solutions
okay that is the first anchor tag the
drive tag is getting closed and we would
like to start
another div tag and in this div tag we
would like to say
class equal to
navbar
underscore
items
okay
within this div tag we would like to use
this human
and within this ul i would like to use
this li
okay and in this ally
uh
we would like to bring some
ahref
equal to
hash
that is the link which i need to provide
okay
so in this anchor tag we want to provide
a location called home here the first
list item which is there
like this i can provide some other list
items too
like i need to talk about call about
we're saying hash
about and here we say
about here
so this anchor tag is getting closed
okay
and
here before i close this list item here
you would like to take another url tag
okay in this url tag we would like to
paste this list item again
and here with this hash we can just give
the name call
something whichever you want to give it
again
blank and
empty
so after that ul is also getting closed
li is also getting closed here
okay
after this
we can provide few more li tags here
okay so
href equal to here we would like to
provide a real url remove the hashtag
and say
https
simplyland.com
slash
corporate hyphen
training
okay and here we will be giving
the option called services
this falls into the category of what
services
like this we would like to provide one
more anchor tag for contact us
that's the
contact
one more for our team
okay and here we say
our t
okay let me go back to my index.html
file and check
illustrators
well it looks pretty nice now here we
have got simply learn solution with us
and right inside you can see now here in
about you see how the things are working
for me
this links are coming up automatically
it came because here if you remember
in my code
when i was saying this about
okay this was a part of our current code
and due to that it is now making it
possible for us
and that is possible because here in why
style.css
if you remember
we were using this
a kind of
navbar uli
okay so the moment i try to hover
okay so this was giving me the complete
details and due to that
i was in position to get all the details
so it looks pretty nice
okay so going forward what i would like
to do is within my program
as i could see in my index.html file we
have provided this
tag so ul is getting close this div is
getting close this tip is also getting
closed
okay
now here we would like to start another
table
we say
dev class equal to banner image
minor underscore
image
okay now within this tip i would like to
use one more div tag within this div we
say
class equal to
banner underscore
content
okay
banner underscore contract now within
this div class we would like to use this
h1
here we can say
welcome to
welcome to simply learn
okay after this
break tag as you know that is a for
break
and now
in this expand tag we can say
words
okay
words
one bootcamp
okay here the h1 tag is getting closed
after that the paragraph tag within this
paragraph we can say
get certified
get
ahead
this value
after this the div tag is getting closed
the second tif tag is also getting close
let me check
okay so that we need to organize it
uh in a better way so but initially we
have a god welcome to safety learn
words number one
bootcamp now
how my look and feel
is really gonna help because this banner
part i want to organize it because i do
not have a css for this
clear so certainly i need a css to
organize
this particular banner
getting it because when you talk about
banner content so i need to tell where
it needs to go because i also would have
some banner image also too so i'll go
back to my css now
and in my style css
here
let me say banner content
banner underscore
content
and here we can say
text align
center and say color
we can say
white smoke
okay
and also within this banner content
we want to use the h1 tag
within this h1 tag you have to just say
text transform
properties
and line height
line height 30 pixels
okay and
margin bottom
this margin bottom we want to use 15
pixels
okay
so that's when we have it let me close
this
sorry and here we want to use one more
property called banner content
with h1 and the span tag so that i can
change the color
so here
banner content
which one we also want to use
span tag
within this i want to say
color
and you can just say
tomato and let's check does it affect my
application
yes exactly it does effect now you can
see it is somewhere coming down the line
like this
okay
so i can further change it
to my application
if i talk about about and all
so this i can change it for sure because
if i have some images also
those images i also want to change
towards my application but it is just a
simple part
we are talking about call banner
and
we have also have to take some images
too
for this banner image
so let's go back
and talk about our index.html file and
see
what some of the balance i want to
utilize it here
okay
now when we talk about get ahead i
certainly need some of the banner image
too but banner image is not available so
let me go back and try to use some
banner image whichever we have to define
under my
css okay so here in my style css let me
go here and say
dot
banner underscore
image
in this banner image we have to say
background url
background
colon obviously
url and in this url we have to use this
image called images
slash p4
dot jpg
that will be my image and also we would
like to use one very common option that
is called no repeat
so that it should not repeat it and i
want to fix it to the top
and in the center
okay now let's check
perfect it is coming up but it is not
looking as good as it looks like it
so we want to use few more important
things like this background size
background size
covered and also want to use width
width i want to use 100
and height
we want to use it called 600 percent
okay display
we want to use it flex
and
justify content
we want to use it called center
and align items
center let's check this out
okay now you can see it looks pretty
better
compared to the previous version
whatever we have written it
but this image needs to be look even
more better
okay and the content needs to be
more awesome
but anyways that is the first thing
which we have written after that we have
to write an about us and other areas but
that is initially which i would like to
make it
even more better and more look
okay
okay so we have seen the value still uh
call option called get certified get
ahead the div tag is getting closed and
i want to use another
div
and inside this div we want to say
class equal to about
okay and
id equal to about
okay
and within this div tag i want to use
this h1 tag
with the statement tag i say
class equal to
title
okay here i want to say
about us
actual time is closed after that i want
to define this paragraph and want to
give some details about a simple learn
okay like
and talk about simply learn
words number one
training okay we can just
provide
you know some details training providers
that's it so
we can write it that much about in
paragraph tag
and we can use this tab again
within this tab we
say to
plus equal to
bdn
and say
a
href
equal to
and in the search results we would like
to say
colon
simply learn
dot com okay slash
resources and here we can just give the
option name called
done
more
to this anchor tag the div tag is
getting close later on
okay and now
just like in dev we have provided here
we can also offer the details with
regards to your
services like to provide title is same
about us we can say our services
our services
so
you can give any details if you want
okay paragraph
now
here after this paragraph using div
class equal to
div
underscore services
and
we may not have any href right over here
so we're removing this href tag
okay dip class equal to
diff on sigma x paragraph
d i
developed this services
here we want to use another div tag
and uh
in this div tag we want to say
class equal to
enter underscore
services
underscore
item
we have to basically provide
and within this i have to use this
option called img
src equal to now you have to provide a
location so i'm saying
under this images folder we have a call
services
of course services one
dot jpg alt equal to
in case of the service is not available
you can just say
service underscore image
okay within this
once this is close you like to use a s3
diagonal
and in this h3 tag i just say
class
equal to
sub underscore
title and here we get the title name
called
web development let me go back and check
yeah so i can see this option called
about us is coming up
learn more if i talk about learn more
you see i'm taking you to the
website of this
simply learn resources which are
available to us so this link is working
perfectly fine
and
i can see here called our services
it is the same
well going back so we have a call
this our services
so alt equal to
services underscore image
sd class equal to subtitle web
development
and
that's it
so the div tag is getting closed here
and i may choose to
talk towards
diff service item so let me have
another div tag here
and
in this div tag we say
class equal to
dev
underscore
services underscore item
div underscore services underscore item
okay now within this dev tag
okay
so
what you want to offer now
i want to offer some again certain
images
so what those images will be let me try
to copy this
and the s3 tag to let me copy this again
service one i'm giving call service to
service underscore images so underscore
title rather than using web development
we can say app development
okay
so this div tag i will copy it again
which is getting closed and try to use
one more
so deep underscore service underscore
item again images i'll say
service 3 instead service image and here
i can say online certification
online certification
okay
so
like this
all the three dip tags are getting close
now and after that we will start
meanwhile let me check
so these image sizes are pretty big so i
just want to make them small
but initially they are okay
okay you can see we have called our
services
okay
so
you can see like web development
so image sizes are pretty big which we
can
make them small
to cover up the way they are supposed to
but this way we'll be doing it little
later on let's go ahead and talk about
the complete html portion which we want
to complete it now
okay so that online certification we
have taken
so also the three div tags are getting
closed now here onwards
we want to start the another tab
okay with this div we want to say class
equal to
equal to we want to use contactors
we want to say contact us and here
id equal to
contact us
let me try to wrap it with this single
quotes
okay and here we use this h1 tag
within this h1 tag we say
class equal to
title here
and uh here i say contact us
contact us okay that is for the post h1
tag we are using it now
after that let's start with another div
tag
with this div we want to use class
equal to
form
underscore
wrapper
okay div class equal to what form
underscore what wrapper
div
again
okay
class equal to
form underscore what input
and here we say
the input tag
so it is input applicable to what a
check box for me
so i would like to say
text instead input applicable to what
text and
just say remove the name and id and say
placeholder equal to
email
okay so this div tag is getting closed
after that i can also use
so for
i would say subject as well as for
message i copy this
form input
so once again
placeholder
subject
and
once again placeholder equal to what
three options we are using it right now
okay do
after this
once it is over we would like to use
another div tag
and do
class equal to
btn
and within this i want to use
some anchor tag
a hf equal to hash
setup equal to what hash
and want to use submit
okay that's it
now
now you can see we have got these three
properties are coming up at the end
but certainly we can go back and try to
fix those images
which are there behind the scene
okay using what the style
so
first important thing is
we have got this images with us
what those images are if we just check
here
we have a call
dev service item
okay we have a call what dev service
item so that we want to change it but
before that i will go back to my style
and after this h1 span we want to use
for dot
about
ok dot
service we press enter
service
or i can say services
here we talk about dot
contact us
we also talk about dot dot
our team
okay
so these four properties we are going to
use it by saying
text align
center and
[Music]
adding five percent
ten percent
okay
now
we talk about services so we saying dot
services
with the services we can say
background
white
now we would like to provide the div
services where we have this options with
us we say dot
div underscore
services
here
margin top
25 pixels
from margin top here same after that
display
we are selecting this call type selects
also justify contents
of type space between
for dev services
now in this div services we may get many
different type of options okay
this is the first dev service now in the
same option in dot
dev services
space
we talk about dev services underscore
item
okay
and here we want to say with
30
okay now
i copy the same
in this div services item
so we want to use
image part that is the most important
area
here we say
width
100
okay and margin button
okay margin bottom 25 pixels
okay
okay now you can see this images looks
pretty nice
yeah looks better
so that's how you see your websites are
really creating some difference compared
to the previous one now they're aligned
properly and
you can see here
these images are really nice
okay that's the benefit so we have this
let me call the glasses
yeah
and
once this image part is closed we would
like to talk about h3 part
let me copy this
item
and with this item we say ashtray
and this s3 will say color
tomato and margin bottom
these are 15 crystals
okay for this h3
and when it comes to this text boxes
certainly you can change the look and
feel how you really want it
so for this you can say dot
form underscore
rebel
home underscore
input
okay form wrapper form input
we say
margin hyphen bottom
15 pixels
okay perform input
now in a similar line
form input we may have a hot text area
input
text area and in this text area we
want to offer some of the details like
i'm talking about like in width we talk
about padding
let's talk about like in the width
i'm saying 250 pixels
okay we said padding
we say two pixels
and 20 pixels
we talk about
height
80 pixels we talk about resize
we talk about
none we say border
this bottle we say 1 pixels
solid
and
white
this is for this and in a similar one i
can use it for the text box so form
colon input
whatever we have used it
form wrapper
form input so let me copy this
okay form input and here we say input
equal to
type of text
so what
combination you'll be using so i'll be
using width padding and border
click copy
i need ridge padding and border height
and
we're removing it
and
awesome
so they look
pretty nice
okay so we have this three text boxes
with us
and all are looking nice the way
we are expecting from our application
okay so that's the one
which my application is offering about
this text area and all
so that looks really nice the way we are
expecting right now
okay
so
what are the areas we have seen
tiff services
item
and everything whichever you are saying
like this
so let's go back and check
my index.html file
so we have a call
form wrapper which is the outermost
okay
you see now here it contains lot many
things
so here in my
program when i see like form wrapper
okay
form underscore wrapper
dot form input
and uh
talk about like the other details
talk about input type equal to text
you see like the border is like that
so if you want to have this border some
different color
and certainly use black
now you can see it looks pretty nice
because earlier it was looking like
pretty much different now at least i can
see
here the location has been given
okay uh so going back towards the
previous
html page so we had a call a submit
button with us
okay after this the
all three div tags are getting closed
and now onwards we would like to start
working with team details
so we are saying div
so div
plus equal to
our t
and
id equal to
team again
okay and now we want to use this h1 tag
here this h1 tag we say
class
plus equal to title
and here i say
13
in a h1 tag
now once it is over we will use again
another div tag
which having
class equal to our team wrapper
our
team
underscore
wrapper
now within this step tag
we want to use one more div tag
here in this
class equal to
team underscore or team iphone one
base
team
what is the div tag now here we will be
using a lot of other div tags inside
this like
i say div
class equal to team members
team members
okay
and uh
data hyphen
name equal to you can give any name like
let's give the name call
it's like space k
okay
and within this
i want to use one image tag
img space src equal to
images
team one
dot jpg
okay
so that's the first thing
we have it so this div tag is closed now
uh i copy the same
the total i want to use this three one
two
three
and
here team members i would like to change
the name here
rather than display let me get the name
called
and
one more
that is gone
okay and change the name to
forward five three
okay so this is the first div we have
used it so this dream tag is getting
closed right over here
along with this the second dip tag is
getting closed
so after having this
two div tags closed we want to use
another one so for team two
okay so i just copy the same
okay uh
i would like to go ahead with
team two team so team members
and uh here i would like to say four
five
four
five
six
and change the name
like
you can give anything i just give the
name called
suppose
and
so these names we are using it now let's
go back and see how it really looks
so these images are coming like that
okay
so we want to use those images in
somewhere not like this or horizontal
vertical so this spot fix that issue i
have to once again look back to it to my
styles
okay where
this option can be used in better way
i like to go back to my style.css
and want to use
the first option called dot over three
background
sorry
background now here we say
white smoker
now
again
poverty
wrapper
so in this i would like to say display
flex
and flex direction
space between
oh sorry column
let's check how it really looks like and
this is no more change
but
certainly few more classes can really
make a difference
so our team
okay underscore rapper
let's check this is the same name we
have used it
yes our team
now in the same way we want to use this
team
so
again our team wrapper
okay
dot
team
display
click
and justify contents
space between
okay
now here
we talk about t
we also want to say uh
our team underscore wrapper
dot
team
underscore
members
here we would like to give width
how much 30
and height
this will be auto
and here we'll be having cursor
pointer for sure
and overflow
hidden
and position
relative
this is for team members
now you can see it looks better now now
we have to basically divide those
because we have got separate team
members are available so we have to also
divide them too so here after this we
want to say
dot
our team
wrapper and again dot
team member
space img
these images we say
display
block
width
100
okay
height
auto
okay
transition
transition
or
transition i can say or type all
like this
okay and in a similar way
copy this team
and we'll say members
over
image and we can say
transform
scale
1.1
that's it
okay so we have this
look and feel appeared
okay with
transition image over so they're all
ready with us
okay everybody so after writing all
those the only difference i made it like
i had used hyphen but i'm using
underscore here
finally when i see my look and feel
of this
i can see now it is moving you can see
now it is all moving
okay so that gives me the confidence of
like yes exactly the code is working the
way it was expected earlier
in my index.html file
okay so once this portion is over
okay we want to go ahead so three tip
tags are getting close one two and three
and here
we would like to start working with a
footer so here we start
folder
so within this footer i say class equal
to
button
okay now after this i use container
there
okay
div class equal to what container
and again
div
equal to
row
okay
now
div class equal to rho again another div
equal to
footer hyphen col
call footer hyphen column
now let me use h4
within this h4 i say
company
okay
after this we want to use this ul
within this um
once again
i want to use some
link items
uh
list items within this list item
a
equal to
so this hrf tag we want to say
hdb okay we have already used this
simplyrun.com url
here
let me copy this
come down
http.com rather than resources i can say
about us
about hyphen us
and here we say about us
it is getting closed
so
i copy this line again
okay
so
one more thing i want to use it think
href equal to
dash
and here we will say
our team
okay
after that
we want to offer the careers so we save
and we want to use
careers
here
review
concept
aluminum speak
so this is the detail of this so the ul
tag is getting close
and after the serial tag is getting
closed
we want to use one more div class equal
to footer hyphen column
okay i copy this
it is getting closed here
okay so do classical to photo hyphen
column so rather than using company we
want to use test cover
discover
and here in this discover we say
simplylink.com and here we have this
option called skillup
hyphen
free iphone
[Music]
online iphone
portal
okay so here we will give the name call
scale up
okay
after this
we have this called careers we say
resources
we remove this
resources
here we can give the name call resources
again
resources
we have called tutorials
tutorials
reset
tutorials here
so like this we can create as my number
of urls as i want
okay
so
once it is over
let me copy this again
and here
photocolumn we say follow us
follow
us
or else we can say this option name
called work with us
but
with because
in this work with us
we can have
some options with us and you will
remove those two
in this we would like to say guest
blogging
we say
guest
blogging
yes blogging we can say blog is guest
blog
guest
another link which i have it here that
is called become our trainer
here we say
become hyphen our iphone
trainer and we say
become an instructor
okay
so like that you're offering it and
once it is done
i can copy it once again this
do and
provide few more
photo hyphen column
followers
okay
and
[Music]
follow us we would like to use another
table
okay we say
class
equal to
social hyphen
links and this dev tag will be closed
later
okay
templars equal to social links
in this i can have some facebook.com
and
you know twitter.com and many more
names i can take it so here in our
dev classical social link here i would
not be using any url here
i would not be using any ally here
okay so i'm closing this even in a live
closing this url and i like
to
well simplyname.com or else we can just
give the name called twitter.com
okay
twitter.com
learn
okay
so
we can offer the user
to
follow us on
instagram also or the
twitter also so here we say
a hdf
but what we need to give it so we can
situate.com
slash simply learn
we remove this values whichever we have
it so instead we use this i
okay and in this i i say
equal to
okay anchor tag is closed
so in case if you want to talk about
like a
typical uh
[Music]
you know instagram that instagram also
you can use it now so here
we say http www
dot install
we say instagram.com
okay slash
simply learn underscore
underscore e-learning
okay and i want to use the same option
there also
i
entered this
remove this
okay
so here you just give the name called fa
hybrid
instructor
now let's go back and check
okay so you can see now we have got this
links coming up for facebook as well as
what
of this instagram so that looks really
nice that gives us a feeling of yes
exactly the code the way we are looking
forward for it is working
the way it was expected
okay
and
if you want to offer
any
other type of details that also you can
offer but this is the first thing which
we have taken so this is the navigation
links are available
these navigation links
you can also change the way they always
look forward for so i'll be providing
some links which we can later on use it
okay everyone so finally we are all
ready so i have basically added some of
the additional styles to my code you can
see here from
this one downwards we've added this
image url
this is for body this is for star
container row ul
this is for footer
this is for photo column so because we
are also using some photo portions into
my code as you can see we will call
photo column and photo class equal to
what
footer so implemented this photo
background color equal to black we have
used it padding 70 pixels photo column
footer column because we are using this
h4 tag also you remember like we're
using this h4 tag also
so for all h4 tags this would be the
basic setting
for footer column h4 before we would
like to give the contents like this by
giving this background color height box
sizing width and then all
footer column unli not last side we
gonna give this margin bottom and this
is the style for photo column uli and
list items
clear and here you can see this font
size we are giving it this is for over
this is for photo column where we have
our social links whichever we have
created so it is showing me the display
line block margin border radius
and this is for social links when i try
to click on or over it so the color will
change to this white color
and the media this is for responsiveness
to make sure like in case if i reduce
the size of my browser they look
better the way it is expected
so when the line size will change to 720
pixels so this color will be changed and
this is the styles for aero photo one
this all we have implemented and finally
my application when i refresh
it actually looks like that see now this
is the photo area of my application
so i'm sure that this looks even more
better and convenient because when i try
to
reduce the size
you see now it's still going to give you
the responsiveness
can you see this now this is going to
give you the responsiveness reason
because here we are using this
logic for
media when the change
of width will to 720 pixels if it is
going to 767 pixels so like that you
implement that so guys our project is
now ready i'm sure that you enjoyed
thank you very much for enjoying this
project so final our application is set
and our application is working the way
it is supposed to work for us html
stands for hypertext markup language it
is the most widely used language for
developing web applications it was
created by berners-lee in the year 1991
but it was published in the year 1995.
html4 was a popular breakthrough version
and got published in the year 1991.
this version gained a lot of popularity
and was adopted all over the globe for
developing web applications so without
further ado let's get started with the
interview questions based on html it's
the first question
what is html html stands for hypertext
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet html
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that format it properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now
what are html tags
so the answer for this question is html
tags are used for placing the elements
in a proper and appropriate format tags
use the symbols greater than and less
than to set them apart from the html
content
the html tags need not to be closed
always for example in case of images the
closing tags are not required for an
image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are html
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an html
tag that change the way the tag behaves
or displayed for example an image tag
an image stack has src attribute with
which you can use the source from which
you have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the html tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tags
now followed by third question we have
our next question what is mark you in
html mark you is used for scrolling text
on a web page it scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a marquee you have to use
marquee tags
now we have our fifth question how do
you separate a section of text in html
we separate a section of text in html
using the below tags which are the break
tag paragraph tag and block code
the break tag is used to separate a line
of text it breaks the current line and
shifts the flow of the text line to a
new line followed by that we have the
paragraph line the paragraph line is
used to write a paragraph of text and
third one the block code the block code
tag is used to define large quoted
sections
now we have our sixth question define
the types of lists in html so we have
the three types of lists in html which
are the ordered list unordered list and
definition list so first we'll discuss
the ordered list the ordered list uses o
l tag and displace elements in a
numbered format next we have the
unordered list the unordered list uses
ul tag and displace elements in a
bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
dl dt and dd tags and displays elements
in the form of definition
like a dictionary
next we have our seventh question
how do you align list of elements in an
html file we can align the list elements
in an html file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains
now we have our eighth question
differentiate between ordered list and
unordered list so the answer for this
question is an unordered list uses ul
tags and each element of the list is
written between li tags the items are
displayed as bullets rather than numbers
now coming into ordered list so for
creating an ordered list you will be
using ol tags and each element inside
the list is written using li tags the
list items are displayed using numbers
rather than bullet points now we have a
sample on the screen right now so the
first three elements are a
set of unordered lists which are
represented using bullet packs and the
second set which is the coffee tea and
milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question how do you display a table in
html web page so the table and html can
be created or displayed using the table
tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example header section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below are a
list of html tags used for displaying
table in an html web page so we have
table tr th et cetera et cetera table is
used to define a table tr is used to
define a row in a table th for header td
for a cell caption is used to define a
caption and we have the call group which
is used to specify a group of one or
more columns in a table for formatting
next we have call which is used with
call group element to specify column
properties for each column next we have
t body which is used to group the body
content in a table next we have t head t
footer which are used for header content
and footer content respectively moving
forward we have our 10th question
how do you display the given table in an
html webpage so the answer for this
question is written on the right side
part of my screen this is the sample
code which you can use to represent or
display a table which is given in this
particular format over here now followed
by this we have our 11th question how do
we insert a comment in html so the
answer for this question is
we can insert a comment in html by
beginning with lesser than sign and
ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
html so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using ampersand copy semicolon
or ampersand
169 semicolon in an html file now moving
ahead we have our 13th question so
what is a white space in html so the
answer for this question is an empty
sequence of space characters is called
as white space in html
this white space is considered as a
single space character in html white
space helps the browser to merge
multiple spaces into one single space
and so taking care of indentation
becomes easier
white space helps in better organizing
the content and tags making them
readable and easy to understand
with this let's move into the 14th
question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same html webpage so
the answer is anchor tags we can use anc
attack along with referencing through
the use of hashtag symbol to create
several links to different sections
within the same web page moving ahead we
have the 15th question how do you create
a hyperlink in html so the answer is we
can use anchor tag again here the same
thing we can use anchor tag to create a
hyperlink within the html that links to
another web page the hyperlink can be
added to images too now moving ahead
into our 16th question define an image
map so the answer for this question is
an image map in html helps in linking
with the different kinds of web pages
using the single image it can be used
for defining spaces in the images that
are made part of the image mapping
process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in html a
stylesheet helps in creating a
well-defined template for html web page
that is both consistent as well as
portable a single style sheet template
can be linked to various web pages which
makes it easier to maintain and change
the look of the website now the 18th
question
what is semantic in html
so the answer for this question is
semantic html is a coding style it is
the use of html markup to reinforce the
semantics or the meaning of the content
for example the semantic html b tag is
not used for bold statement as well as i
tag which is not used for italic instead
we use strong and em tags
now followed by the 18 question we have
our 19th question
what is svg in html so the html svg is
used to describe the vector or raster
graphics svg images and their behaviors
are defined in xml text sheets it is
mostly used for vector type diagrams
like pie charts two dimensional graphs
in an x y coordinate system now moving
ahead we have our 20th question
what would happen if there is no text
between the html tags so the answer for
this question is really simple there
would be nothing to format if there is
no text present in between the tags
therefore nothing will appear on the
screen some tags such as the tags with
our closing tag like image tag do not
require any text between them
now followed by the 20th question we
have our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an html so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages in html using the built-in
iframe tag the html live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source
which redirects the user to simply
learns official webpage
now followed by that we have our 22nd
question how do you add buttons in html
so we can use the built-in button tag in
html to add buttons to the html web page
so on the right hand part of my screen
you can see the implementation of button
to an html web page now followed by 22nd
question we have our 23rd question
what are the different types of headings
in html so the answer for this question
is there are basically six types of
heading tags in html which are defined
with h1 to h6 stacks
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another
where h1 is being the largest and h6 is
being the smallest so on the right hand
part of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from h1
to h6 now the
output for this particular code segment
is the h1 h2 s3 h4 h5 h6 so you can see
that h1 is being the biggest one and h6
is being the smallest one now moving
ahead into our 24th question how do you
insert an image in the html web page so
the answer for this question is you can
insert an image in the html webpage by
using the following code which is
displayed on the right side part of my
screen you can see we have a image
source is equals to tulip dot jpeg
which is used for inserting an image
into your html webpage
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in html now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text in place of
an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded due to any technical issue
so basically when you have poor internet
connection and you are trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the alt attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question
how are hyperlinks inserted in the html
webpage you can insert a hyperlink in
the html webpage by using the following
code which is present on the right side
part of my screen you can use the anchor
tag along with hedge reference and
inside that particular tag you can use
the url to which you want your users to
redirect to
now followed by this we have our 27th
question how do you add color to the
text in html so the answer for this
question is you can add color to the
text by using the following code which
is present on the right side part of my
screen where you can add a red color and
blue color green color to this
particular paragraph and headings now
followed by 27th question we have our
28th question
how do you add css styling in html so
there are three particular ways to add
css to your html there are inline css
external style sheet and internal style
sheet we'll discuss each of these
methods in a bit more detail first we
have the inline css so it is used when
less amount of styling is needed or in
cases where only a single element has to
be styled to use inline styles add the
style attribute in the relevant tag now
moving ahead we have the external style
sheet this is used when the style is
applied to many elements or html pages
each page must link to the style sheet
using the link tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single html document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format internal style
sheet is added in the head section of
the html page by
style tag now followed by this we have
our 29th question
what hierarchy do the style sheets
follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add javascript to an html web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
javascript to our html webpage they are
inline script block and
external javascript file first we'll
discuss the inline
you can add javascript to your html
elements directly whenever a certain
event occurs javascript code can be
added using attributes of the html tags
that support it now the next one that is
the script block you can define a script
block anywhere inside the html code
which will get executed as soon as the
browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script blocks are
usually added at the end part of the
html documents now the last one that is
the external javascript file you can
also add or import the javascript code
from a separate file and keep your html
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the html webpage so
this session will be about become a
front-end developer
so let us begin
we are going to discuss the things you
need to know to become a web developer
first we will start with basic skills
which every web developer must know
before moving into more advanced web
frameworks
then we will understand what react is
and why it is so popular after that we
will go through another web framework
called angular
then we will also get to know about a
comparatively new front-end framework
called vue in the end
we will go through the front-end
developer salary trends which will give
you an insight of the job market
so without further ado let's get started
first the basic skills
let us understand what basic skills are
required to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path
these are the common things every
programmer should know
the first one is the github
so git is a free open source version
control system that enables
collaborations in a particular project
it is designed to handle both small and
large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the feature updates in the
product or an application
so followed by the github the next
important thing we have is the data
structures and algorithms a data
structure is the location used to store
and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
allow us to write efficient and fast
computer programs
so followed by data structures and
algorithms we have the text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice
visual studio code is the top choice for
most of the web developers and my
personal choice too because of the large
support of languages and of course
the speed
the text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line the command line is an
important tool to get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing it on a text editor
the better you are on the command line
the more efficient you will be as
developer
so followed by the command line we have
the http and https the http protocol is
the backbone of the internet
it handles requests and responses from a
web application it is mandatory for a
web developer to have good knowledge of
both http and https in order to build
fast and responsive web applications
now that we know what basic skills are
required to become a front-end developer
let's discuss about the most popular
front-end library that has to react
now what exactly react is
so react is a front-end javascript
library used for building beautiful user
interface components
it is an open source meaning it can be
used in your commercial projects without
any restrictions
it is also component based and these
components can be used again and again
promoting code reusability
it is an mvc or model view controller
architecture
react is the v responsible for how the
application looks and feels for the end
user now why should you learn react
react has always been in high
performance as it uses virtual dom
rather in real dom
so basically dom stands for
document object model and is used by
every internet browser for rendering a
web page or an application
react can also be easily integrated with
other javascript frameworks like node.js
resulting in the development of a
completely
new web application including front end
and the back end
it is comparatively easy to maintain
large-scale applications written in
react because
it highly promotes code reusability and
code
readability so followed by react the
next important thing we have is the
angular
we have an idea of what react is but it
is not the only framework used for
building user interfaces so now let us
know about angular
so now what exactly angular is
angular unlike react is a fully fledged
framework for web application
development which usually does not
require additional libraries for
implementing additional functionalities
like routing
it is also open source and backed by
google and as regularly updated
resulting in constantly improved
performance and addition of new features
in terms of performance it was begged to
be much slower than react but with the
recent versions performance seems to be
on par with react
now why should you learn angular
angular is one of the most stable
frameworks out there
it is also the most complete meaning you
don't have the need to integrate with
other frameworks since it's pretty much
includes everything for the web
development of a complete web
application
angular backed by google is safe choice
for using in long-term projects since it
is not going anywhere anytime soon
angular is obviously used by google for
its web applications and also used by
other large-scale companies creating a
lot of job opportunities
now followed by angular the next one we
have is the view
now that we know quite a bit about the
two popular front-end frameworks namely
react and angular let's now go ahead
into
view and learn a bit more about vue.js
library
now what exactly is vue
vue is a lightweight and open source
progressive javascript framework used
for developing interactive web user
interfaces
it is meant to be integrated with other
libraries to develop a complete web
application
like react vue.js is mainly focused on
the view part of the web application and
hence it's a bit faster when compared to
angular
which is a complete web application
solution
view.js is commonly referred to as view
and pronounced as vue.js or view is
rightly so
now why should you learn vue
any beginner web developer can easily
understand view and start building their
own web user interfaces
like react view also uses virtual dom
resulting in better performance and it
also uses the component-based code
design promoting core reusability and
code readability
vue.js has become popular in recent
times and many companies are starting to
use it owing to its lightweight
performance and easy integration with
other web libraries and frameworks
now with this let's move into the next
section where we will discuss about the
front-end developer salary trends
now that we know what skills we need to
become a front-end developer let's now
have a look into the sale regions of a
front-end developer
front-end developers are always in high
demand since new web applications are
launched and managed continuously
there are generally offered generous
salaries across the globe
the salaries also depend on the factors
like frameworks skills and the work
experience
the average salary of a front-end
developer in india is five lakh six
thousand rupees per annum
the average salary of a front-end
developer in united states is 76
929 us dollars per annum this session
will be about web development roadmap in
2021
so let us begin
assuming that you know what web
development is the roadmap is divided
into three sections the first section is
all about the common skills which every
web developer should know while the
second and third are about front-end and
the back-end development the main areas
of web development
so you can either learn front-end or
back-end or both depending upon your
choice so if you want to become a full
stack web developer then you have to
learn both front end and the back end
there is no escaping there
in the end we will also go through the
salaries of web developer so without
further ado let's get started
the first one that is the common skills
let us understand the basic skills that
you require to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path
these are the common things every
programmer should know
the first one is git
get is a free and open source version
control system that enables
collaboration in a particular project it
is designed to handle both small and
large-scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the future updates in a product
or application
the next one is the data structures and
algorithms a data structure is a
location used to store and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem learning data
structures and algorithms will allow us
to write efficient and fast computer
programs
followed by data structures we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice next visual studio is the
top choice of the most web developers
and my personal choice too because
it has a large support of languages and
of course the speed
next
text editor is where you write all your
code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
a command line is an important tool that
you need to get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing your code on the text editor
the better you are on the command line
the most efficient you will be as a
developer so followed by command line
interface you have the http or https
the http protocol is a backbone of the
internet it handles the requests and
responses of a web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of both http and
https in order to build a fast and
responsive web application
so followed by common skills we have the
front-end developer
front-end development is all about
developing the user interface and its
interaction with the client end
let's go ahead and look into this field
of web development
there are a few things that you must
know for becoming a front-end developer
let's discuss these things
so the first one is the web development
basics it is necessary to know the
basics of web before moving on to
programming languages next you should
know stuff like web applications
protocols like http and web development
in general so followed by web
development basics we have the html and
css
html and css are the backbones of any
website html provides the structure
while css provides their style to make
them visually appealing
mastering these two technologies is a
must to become a front-end developer
browser in the end renders html and css
on the webpage regardless of the
technology used to develop that page
followed by html and css we have the
javascript javascript is an extremely
important technology that every web
developer should learn
most of the popular web frameworks like
react.js and node.js are built upon the
javascript
javascript makes the web applications a
love by adding interactivity and dynamic
updating of web applications followed by
javascript we have the typescript
typescript can be considered as an
extension of javascript angular uses
typescript as a space language it adds
type safety to javascript to cache
errors in the development phase it also
helps in developing object oriented code
for javascript so followed by typescript
we have the angular
angular is a web framework used to
create a single phase applications
it is backed by google therefore
learning angular is a good choice for a
modern web developer
so followed by angular we have
react js react is a popular library for
developing fast and responsive web
applications
it is backed by facebook and quite
popular because of its simplicity and
performance
it allows you to create a reusable
components that can be used to create
modern web applications
so followed by react.js we have view js
view is like other front-end frameworks
that is used for building user
interfaces
it is comparatively easier to integrate
view with other libraries or existing
projects
it is a newer framework but it has
really picked up speed last year and
being adopted more
now followed by the front-end developer
we have the back-end developers
so back-end development is more about
caring how application works and ensure
that it keeps running smoothly let's go
ahead and know more about this field of
web development
there are a few things that you must
learn for becoming a back-end developer
let us discuss those things
so the first one is the node.js node.js
is a javascript runtime built on
chrome's v8 javascript engine it allows
you to develop a complete web
application using javascript
it is best suited to be used for web
applications in conjunction with
javascript frameworks like react.js
so followed by node.js we have python
python is a popular language used in
various fields of tech applications
django is a back-end framework based on
python used for server-side scripting it
is also known for its speed and
efficiency python is also easy to get
started with programming language if
this is your first time coding followed
by python we have java
java has been the most used language for
a long time it is primarily used for
back-end development you can either use
core java or java with spring boot for
high performance back end
next we have
next we have ruby ruby is a dynamic
programming language that focuses mainly
on simplicity
it has a syntax that is very easy to
read and close to english language
phrases
the web framework ruby on rails is
popularly used for developing packing
systems so followed by ruby we have php
and mysql
php although treated as a hard to learn
language is still the easiest way to
write server-side code
at least 50 percent of the internet runs
on php and mysql
mysql is the most popular database for
storing data of a web application
now followed by the backend developer we
will enter the next important stage of
web development roadmap in 2021 that is
about the web developers salary trends
let's now have a look on the salary
trends of a web developer web developers
are always in demand since new web
applications are launched and managed
continuously they are generally offered
generous salaries across the globe
salaries also depend on the types of web
developers for instance full stack
developers are paid more than the front
end and backend developers
the average salary of a web developer in
india is 3 lakh 86 000 per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is 68
524 u.s dollars per annum i'm sure
you've all heard the phrases software
development and web development
and i wouldn't be surprised if you used
them interchangeably or even mistook a
software developer for a web developer
well let me break your bubble
they are different
today's topic of discussion is software
developer versus web developer
so moving ahead who is a web developer
now a web developer builds and maintains
websites and other web applications he
takes web design and turns it into a
website
web developers are responsible for how a
website or web application looks and
functions from its user interface and
page layout to back-end systems for
gathering data
a web developer is expected to
collaborate with clients stakeholders
and organization leaders to design
unique and engaging websites for
businesses non-profits government
agencies and anyone else who is looking
to communicate more effectively online
so diving a bit deeper a web developer
can specialize in different areas based
on their skill you have the front-end
developers now these are experts who are
in charge of how websites and
applications look and function from the
user's perspective
next there are back-end developers who
focus on the technical aspects of
websites and web applications that
support both
basic and advanced functionality
now they largely work on administrative
components which include databases
website architecture application logic
creating new apis and user interfaces
based on predefined specifications
and lastly there are full stack
developers who are professionals
responsible for the development of an
application from start to finish
they specialize in both front end and
back end of the application development
typically a web developer should have
good skills in various frameworks and
markup languages like html css
javascript
react chairs angular and database
management systems like mongodb
and back-end tools like node
so i hope this helped you understand who
a web developer is some of their
responsibilities and their basic skill
set
next up
let's understand who a software
developer is
now software developers are responsible
for creating more complex applications
and programs for computers and mobile
devices
they create conceptualize program
document test and upgrade software and
their components
software developers invent manage and
optimize computer programs that run on
desktops laptops smartphones and other
mobile devices
these computer science professionals
write complex code that governs how
desktop applications function
they also specialize in troubleshooting
code bugs
updating user interfaces creating new
tools and much more
just like web developers professionals
in this field are often categorized into
specific roles based on their
specializations
we have the application software
developer and the system software
developer
now an application software engineer is
a professional who focuses on designing
specific desktop and mobile applications
tools and games for consumer audiences
and a system software developer
is largely concerned with designing
systems level software for enterprise
customers rather than the public
the software they develop is used to
manage corporate network apps database
management systems and other critical
infrastructure
talking about their desirable skills
they need to be proficient in
programming in the field of javascript
java c-sharp php python and ruby
they must also have a good understanding
of operating systems network and
database management
so now moving on to the main topic of
discussion software developer versus web
developer
first let's compare the two based on
their prowess or area of expertise
a software developer is associated with
developing products that can be run on
multiple systems
this product could be any kind of
software
their area of work includes requirement
analysis
planning
coding testing of applications
implementation deployment and
maintenance
talking about web developers they are
responsible for the development of
websites
they are also expected to follow the
process of the software development
lifecycle while building their products
next up is the type of product
now a software developer creates
programs for standalone desktop or
mobile platforms
on the other hand a web developer takes
care of the web framework
server-side functions api integration
and the business logic
the third point of comparison is product
compatibility
now software development applications
are compatible across multiple operating
systems or platforms
the web applications on the other hand
are designed to be compatible across
multiple web browsers
next up is the learning curve
well software engineering never focuses
exclusively on coding
however you should know at least a
couple of languages and a deeper
understanding of how they function
some of the languages that you should be
proficient in include java c-sharp
python and some of its libraries and
frameworks javascript and ruby among
others
a web developer should be familiar with
markup languages like html css
javascript libraries and frameworks like
react and angular
you should also have a good hold of back
in frameworks like python django and
node
the next parameter is a job title
now there are different job titles for
these professions
some of them for software development
are software developer software engineer
junior software developer senior
software developer and a software
architect
on the other hand a web developer could
receive titles like front-end developer
back-end developer full-stack developer
or just a web developer now of course
companies have discretion over assigning
these job roles to their employees
lastly let's look at the job outlook and
salaries
now the job growth projections for
software developers are even more
optimistic than those for web
development roles
alongside promising job growth software
developers also have higher salaries
than other it professionals
now the average salary of a software
developer in the us is around 76 000 us
dollars per annum
and the average salary of a software
developer in india is around 5 lakh
indian rupees per annum
for a web developer the average salary
in the u.s is around 68 000 us dollars
per annum and in india it's around 4
lakh indian rupees per annum
now i'm sure you must be confused as to
which one to choose
well to be frank it's just a matter of
preference if you have strong knowledge
of data structures
file systems algorithms source control
operating and network systems then
software development would be a better
choice
but if you have creative ideas for
websites love designing them have a good
understanding of html and css and
ultimately the knack to integrate your
design ideas to create responsive user
interfaces then a web development role
could be a good career path
then web development could be a better
career path to choose
today's topic is web developer versus a
web designer
now it is extremely common to get
confused between a web developer and a
web designer
now these roles are used interchangeably
given their names and dependency on each
other
however there are a few differences
among them
people aspiring to get into web
development often ask me which role is
suitable for them or rather where do
they fit in or what has to be done
during the process of web development
so i've particularly kept this session
cleared to clarify all your doubts and
provide an insight into both web
developer and web designer roles and
their responsibilities
so let's begin
first let's look at what's in store for
us
we'll first look at what web development
is
then we'll understand who exactly is a
web developer
after that we will have a look at what
web designers actually do
moving ahead will compare between web
developers and designers to give you a
greater insight into both the roles then
we'll look at the current salary trends
of a web developer and a designer in the
tech industry
and lastly we'll conclude with deciding
which role to go for
so without further ado let's get started
what exactly is web development
so web development is a process of
building websites and applications for
the internet
now keep in mind that web development
and web design is seen as different
fields in most of the use cases even
though they collaborate together to
provide the end result that is the web
application
so the web development can be broken
down into three layers that is the
client-side coding which includes the
front-end then you have the server-side
coding which is the back-end and then
you have the database technologies
but who exactly is a web developer
now that we know what web development is
let's understand this
so here are some of the technologies
used by a web developer there's html for
web layout
css for web styling
javascript for making web applications
more responsive and interactive
there's react.js which is a javascript
framework used for front-end development
and then there's nodejs which is a
javascript framework again used for
server-side development
there's mongodb which is a database
technology for storing data for web
applications
and then there's also angular which is
another front-end development framework
based on typescript now there are many
other technologies like php java ruby
etc
and these are most commonly used by all
the web developers
but
you might be wondering who a web
developer is now the role of a web
developer is to build and maintain
websites
he also takes a web design which has
been created by either a client or a
design team and turns it into a website
now web developers are also responsible
for building a product that meets both
the clients needs and those of the
customers and the end users
web developers collaborate with
stakeholders clients and designers in
order to understand the vision
a web developer
also has to perform specific tasks
however these responsibilities may vary
depending on whether they are working as
a front-end back-end or a full-stack
developer
generally full-stack developers
specialize in both the front end and the
back end
so let's go ahead and know more about
each type of web developer in this field
now there are basically three types of
web developers
there's a front-end developers
who build and maintain the client side
of an application
then you have the back-end developers
who work behind the scenes and manage
the services of a web application
and finally you have full stack
developers who manage the project
workflow and work on the required
features of a web application
now let's look at each role in detail
first up when it comes to front-end
developers they usually code the
client-side of a web application
while the back-end developers build and
maintain the services needed by a web
application behind the scenes and then
you have the full stack developer whose
progress is in both front-end and
back-end development
now front-end developers convert the
design into a real-life application
using html javascript and css
back-end developers on the other hand
ensure that the web applications keep
running smoothly
and full stack developers supervise the
development and guide on best practices
front-end developers ensure responsive
and adaptive user interface for your
applications
back-end developers manage services like
api data storage for the web application
and so on
and full stack developers know both the
business requirements and the user
interface requirements
now let's go through the skill set of a
web developer
the skills that a web developer must
have our html that is the markup
language for building web page layouts
css which is the style sheet for styling
the html elements in a website
there's javascript which is a scripting
language for bringing web applications
to life by making them more interactive
and responsive
and he should also know front-end
frameworks like react angular view that
help in making the client side of
applications look better and speed up
the development
moving on you have the back-end
developer skills
there's php which is the backend
language that helps in maintaining all
the work that happens behind the scenes
in a web application
and then there's python which is a very
popular language used in various
software development fields it is used
to handle server-side tasks in web
development
then there's java which is one of the
most used languages for software
development and therefore is also used
in backend development by developers
and then there's database management so
databases like mysql and mongodb are
used for storing data for web
applications
now full stack developers
have skills that cover both front-end
and back-end development of a web
application
therefore they manage the workflow of a
web application development environment
moving on who exactly is a web designer
now here are some of the technologies
used by a web designer
there's adobe photoshop for image
editing and web design
there's adobe illustrator for working
with vectors and scalable web elements
sketch for designing user experience for
web applications
adobe xd also used for user experience
design of web and mobile applications
adobe indesign for marketing campaigns
like banners posters and magazines
there are many other technologies like
adobe after effects blender that are
used by web designers as well
but you might be wondering who exactly
is a web designer
so web designer is one who plans and
designs the layout and other elements of
a website or an application
he performs digital retouching along
with image editing or video editing in
some cases
web designers are responsible for
designing a product that meets both the
clients needs and those of the customers
and end users
he also designs products that are user
friendly appealing and visually
effective
the design is preferably modern and also
easy to use at the same time
so let's go ahead and know more about
the design role
some of the popular design roles include
web designers who design websites and
its elements there is ux designers or
researchers who are responsible for the
user experience of a web or a mobile
application
there are multimedia specialists who
specialize in handling media for web
applications like images and videos
and then you have game designer which is
another role that employs similar tools
as that of web design like adobe
creative cloud
now let's look at each role in detail
a web designer designs the look of
websites and its elements a ux designer
designs and prototypes the look and feel
of web applications and mobile
applications
a multimedia specialist handles media
requirements like editing images videos
etc
then you have the game designer who
designs the props and characters of a
game for various platforms
a web designer typically uses tools like
adobe photoshop and adobe dreamweaver
a ux designer uses tools like adobe
illustrator sketch adobe xd
a multimedia specialist mainly uses
adobe creative cloud which includes
photoshop illustrator and after effects
and then the game designer uses tools
like adobe illustrator autodesk software
blender and unity
so let's go to the skill set of a web
designer the skills that a web designer
must have adobe creative cloud this is
the industry standard software for web
and multimedia design a web designer
must have an imaginative mindset to
design modern web elements
a web designer must also be creative
enough to make the app look visually
appealing
he must also have the ability to give
attention to detail for minor features
and improvements in the web or mobile
applications some of the other soft
skills include communication skills
collaborative mindset and patience
so now let's make a detailed comparison
between web developer and a web designer
so to summarize we've put together
a table for you
so a web developer
builds web applications using languages
like html css and javascript while a web
designer designs the web applications
using tools like adobe photoshop or
sketch
a web developer frequently uses
javascript frameworks for more
streamlined development
while a web designer uses adobe creative
cloud for most of the design needs
a web developer
should possess good coding skills while
a web designer should have good graphic
design skills
web developers have to keep themselves
up to date with the latest web
frameworks and libraries
while web designers have to keep
themselves updated with the latest
design trends and color palettes
so going ahead let's look at the
industry trends
web developers usually have a trend of
earning more than the web designers
still it depends on how well you perform
in your particular job role
so if you are good in web design you
might actually earn more than a fellow
web developer
so the average salary of a web developer
in india is around 3 lakhs 90 000 rupees
per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the united states is around 68 000
per annum
the average salary of a web designer in
india is around 3 lakh 60 000 rupees per
annum
while the average salary of a web
designer in the united states is around
53 000 us dollars per annum
so
moving to the most important question
which one should you choose
it is really a matter of preference
if you have a creative bent of mind and
enjoy using good looking web and mobile
applications and also enjoy designing
them then i would suggest you go for a
web or ux designer role if you have a
technical background like java or python
and you're interested in bringing the
designs to life i would suggest you go
for a web developer role
now that you have learned all about html
let's move on to css here we'll discuss
css selectors css box model css grid
layout and flexbox css display css
positioning difference between flexbox
and grid and css background image and
colors then we'll move on to discuss css
keyframes and animations css transitions
and hover effects css navigation bar
after learning this much we'll look at
some tricks that come in handy when you
write the code after that we look at css
advanced tutorials and responsive design
at last we learn some important
interview questions that are frequently
asked
what are css selectors
css selectors allow you to select and
style html elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their id
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more let's discuss
the most common selectors there are
several different types of css selectors
the most common of them are css element
selectors css id selector css class
selector css universal selector and css
group selectors
so what is the css element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a css selector it means it will
select all the p elements on the page it
will style all the p elements to the
central aligned having blue color
this is a css selector
it is set to p
this means it will select all the p
elements on the page it will style all
the p elements to be center aligned
having blue color
let's look at what it looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with the text color
blue
css id selector the id selector uses the
id attribute of an html element to find
a specific element
an id should be unique within the page
so you should use the id selector to
find a single unique element
to find an element within a specific id
use a hash character followed by the id
of the element
so
here we have used the hash paragon so
all the rules will be applied to the
html element with id equal to para1 so
this is an id selector
it will be applied to all the html
element with id is equal to para1
as you can see it is applied to the
element having the id parameter and all
the other elements are defaultly styled
css class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the html class attribute to
select an html with a specific class use
a period character followed by the name
of the class
so this style will be applied to all the
elements having the class name class 1.
this is a class selector it is denoted
by a period symbol
all the elements having a class name
class 1 will be styled with centrally
aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is styled and all the
other elements are set to default
css universal selector
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a page the universal
selector is assigned by a star character
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a style sheet
as you can see it is denoted by a star
mark all the elements inside our web
page will be centrally aligned and the
color will be set to blue
as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned and the colors are set
to blue
css group selector
in style sheets there are often elements
using the same style to minimize the
code you can group selectors to group
the selectors separate each selectors
with a comma here we have group
selectors for h1 h2 and p
so style is applied to h1 h2 and p
elements only
it is better to group the selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors p h2 and s3
so style will be applied to only
elements having p h2 and s3
as you can see so all the elements of
ph2 and s3 are centrally aligned and
colored to red in this video we will
discuss what is the box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
webpage is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes
css box model typically describes how
these rectangular boxes are laid out on
a web page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different ways but every box
has a content area and optional
surrounding padding border and margin
areas
the following diagram demonstrates how
the content padding border and margin
css properties determine how much space
an element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media it is
bounded by the content edge and its
dimensions are given by the content box
width and height
the border area is the area between the
box padding and margin
its dimensions are given by the width
and height of the border
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin
the dimensions of the margin area are
the margin box width and margin box
height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let's jump to an example to
understand the box model better
so we are on the sublime text later to
get started i have created a box themed
simply background color pink the font
size is 30 pixel and we have set the
border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learn with background going all
the way to the end
i have also removed all the padding and
margin from the page so that the boxes
are pushed just at the corner of the
page
as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the box
if you save the file you can see the box
increased by 20 pixels from all the
sides
padding occurs inside the background of
an element it goes around the content of
the element most of the buttons inside
the css is designed using padding so
that the background of the button
becomes wider than the actual text
the next thing you can do is change the
border of the element
if you change this border size to 15
pixel we will get a nice solid
background of color green
the border goes around the padding of
our element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixel
of water around the padding which is
down the content
now let's see the working of the margin
if we add 30 pixel of margin to our
element you can see the spacing on the
outside of our border
so let's add the 30 pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the border
margin is used to space two elements
apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the
border 20 pixels
and make it color
red
this is 40 pixels
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
by clicking on inspect you can see the
different styles
here in the computer tab you can see the
box model
this is a content area
this is the padding area this is the
border and this is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the
border so you can when you click on this
area you can see the margin
gets highlighted
the border area gets highlighted of 20
pixels
this is the padding and this is the
content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and width
so let's try adding height and width
we'll give the height 50 pixels and
we'll give the width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content area of 15 to 50. in this
tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout then we will move on to the
features of the grid system and some
basic terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand the grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid is the setup intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout so css
gridloud is the most powerful layout
system available in css
it is a two-dimensional system
meaning it can handle both columns and
rows unlike flexbox which is largely a
one-dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the css rules to both the parent element
which became the grid container and the
elements children which become the grid
items
the css grid allowed access at dividing
a page into major regions or defining
the relationship in terms of size
position and layer between parts of a
control build html primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows
however many more regular layouts are
either possible or easier with css grid
than they were with tables for example a
grid container's child element could
position themselves so they actually
overlap and layer similar to the css
positioned elements
so here are the features of the css grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes
you can create a grid with fixed track
sizes using pixels
for example this sets the grid to the
specified pixel which fits to the layout
you desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new fr unit designed for this purpose
you can place the items into a precise
location using the grid
line numbers names or by targeting an
area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items
not given an explicit position on the
grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout the grid layer specification
is flexible enough to add additional
rows and columns when needed
features such as adding as many columns
that will fit into a container are
included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content
more than one item can be placed into a
grid cell or area and they can partially
overlap each other
this layering may then be controlled
with the z-index property
so
here are the basic terminologies you
should know to work with the grid system
better
the grid line is the dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid
they can either be vertical or
horizontal and reside on either side of
rows and columns
a grid column is a space between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
by the grid template column's property
on the other hand a grid row is a space
between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template rows property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
css grid
and in great design a gutter is
basically the width of the space between
columns a gutter margin is this white
space formed by the adjoining inside
margins of two facing pages in a book or
a space between columns on a page
so
with this
let's now move on to the hands-on demo
and see how the grid system works in
actual world so we are in the sublime
text editor open with a project with
some basic background styles and nothing
inside the body
you can see this is a basic background
style we wave pre-applied just to have a
good look of the
box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it
so let's create a grid and give it a
class name grid container
and inside of it we'll put our different
grid items
so we'll just create different grid
items and give them a class grid item
followed by a class number they belong
to
so that we can easily distribute between
them
just copy paste this
five times
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so they are
easy for us to visualize
we have not applied any styles to them
other than the visual styles
so we will go back to our code
let's go back to the css styling sheet
so to create the grid we will open a
style sheet
we need to display grid on our grid
container so we'll select our grid
container and set the display to grid
if you save now
you will see nothing changes this is
because the grid itself doesn't define
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same
to make the grid look actually great
what you need to do is define columns
and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column
we will set the size to 100 pixel 950
pixels
now
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 150 pixel
column on the right
and then the grid captures our next row
but what if we want our box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them
here
we'll use a fraction unit instead of a
150 pixel column we want one fraction of
our size and instead of 100 pixels we
want the two fractions of our size
so we'll just replace with two fractions
and this with one fraction
now if you save the file
and go back to the page
you will see that the items on our left
here in our first column are twice as
large as the item on the second column
and that's because of the fr units we
have defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
the item one is the twice the size of
the item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four columns of size
100 pixel wide you can just write repeat
command and inside of it how many times
you want to repeat the size
so we'll just delete this
and use the repeat
we'll set the number of times we want to
repeat and the size of the
columns
now if you save the file you will see we
have a four columns of 100 pixel wide we
can do the same things for row
just set the grid template
rows and define the size you want
now you can see we have the symmetric
size all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid auto
rows and this will determine the size of
all the rows that is added after the
template rows
suppose we want all our rows to be 100
pixel
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid auto rows to 100 pixels
now you can see all the rules are now
100 pixel tall
let's change our column back to 100
pixel and 150 pixels
so that it'll be easier for us further
we'll just delete this grid auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
now you can see the gaps between the
rows and columns
now we want the same value for both the
columns you can use the grid grab
property and mention the space
we'll just delete this two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid gap
and set the
size to 20 pixels
now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells
so for horizontal positioning we could
use the justify items and we can set
that to center
so that centers each item within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
you can also set it to start
or end
or space around
we will leave this to center
to vertically position the content we
could use the align items
the items also accept the same values
we can set it to center
we can also set this one to start or end
just will keep this to center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them
in a proper manner
we could use the justify content and
that will align the content horizontally
within the container
we can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to center
to align the content vertically we could
use the align content and the align
content also accepts the same value we
can set it to center
or start
if you inspect the elements
you can see they are aligned centrally
between the container
we'll just close this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows it too much in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2d
nature in this video we will learn what
is a flexbox and how it is useful in
designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox
flexbox
also called flexible box model is
basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a css for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assigned width in terms of
percentage or fixed width
and then use the float to arrange the
items on the page
suppose for example you want to arrange
three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from width height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible box
model is the ability to alter the item
width and height to best fit in the
containers available in the free space
flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more effective in small scale
layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
okay so let's jump to some code and
learn how these flex properties work
okay so we are in the sublime text later
to get started let's add a div inside a
body here and we'll give a class of
flexbox container
since this will be the container where
all our flexbox item will reside
then inside this container we will add
another div and give it a class flexbox
item and one more class flexbox item 1
which will help us to understand which
items we are referring to when we style
our elements individually
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because i have already
applied some of the styles to these
flexbox items
let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the items tiled
just a basic styling so that we get the
box on our page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item three
just save the file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
now to create a flex container
we will add display flex to our flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we'll just add
display
flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are in the
same height and they are all in the same
row
you will also notice that if we shrink
our browser the items adjust themselves
accordingly to fit within the browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the main axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container
let's
make it a center
save the file
now you can see that all the elements
are in the center of the page
another thing we can do is if we want
our layout to have a spaces between the
elements we will set the justify content
to space between
you can see all the items are evenly
spaced
if you want to lay out your items on the
cross axis we will use the align items
property
the default value for this is stretch
if we want to keep the size of our items
we will use the center and then all our
items will be centered vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible with flexbox you can
do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container
now let's just delete everything and
we'll just keep the display flex
now if you want to have a column layout
instead we will use the flex direction
and change it to column flex direction
column now if you refresh the page you
will see all the items are shown up in a
column
now we can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as
opposed to flexbox container items
the flexbox container is only for laying
out and spacing between your items as
well as the positioning of your item
inside the container
the actual flexbox item properties are
used to override those item properties
or to apply different sizing to these
elements now if we want our first item
that it does not shrink when we shrink
our browser we'll set the flex shrink to
0 to our first item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to 0. now if you go back to the
page
and try to shrink this
you see the first item remains the same
it does not shrink
now
in the same way you can set the items to
grow in proportion with the web browser
suppose we want our flexbox item to to
grow with the as the page grow and cover
all the empty spaces
so we'll set this flex grow to 1.
now
you will see the all the empty spaces
are taken by the second item
let's say we want our second box to be
the center of the container instead of
stretching to full height
we can use the align self property and
set it to center
now you will see that the alignment
property overrides the align content
property of the container
you can see it is centrally aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the
flexboxes
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the flexbox to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is css display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is the display property
the css display property controls the
layout of the element on the page
the default value of the display
property is block or inline
let's jump back to our sublime text
later to see the various display
properties by using an example to get
started i have a really simple example
setup
as you can see inside my html i have the
two paragraph tags
and i have a formatting
with the background color of sand color
and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drug display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default like how p elements behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the
p element is a display block
so here
this looks something like this
what display blocks does is it means
that it is going to take the entire bit
given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if we change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is inline
the inline display value turns any
element into an inline element
these elements will appear on the same
line without breaks
now if we change here this to display
inline now all the p tabs will behave as
an inline element
now if we go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes the minimum
amount of space possible
as you can see here the sean color takes
the minimum amount of space to fit all
the content inside of this
p
so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible
now one of the demerits here is we
cannot change the height and width of
the inline element
if you change here height to 200 pixels
and width 200 pixels
and save
just go back and refresh
you'll see nothing happens
this is because in the inline display
property you cannot change the height
and width of the element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value the
inline block value is a hybrid of inline
and block element elements assigned
display inline block appears on the same
line with the other inline elements
a characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements also like
block elements in that you can change
the width and height of the css
now if here we try to change the height
and width
of the element
just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and width
property works this is one of the major
difference between the inline block and
the inline inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back and
refresh
you'll see both the element disappears
the display none removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page
this causes accompanying elements to
behave as if this element does not exist
in this video we will discuss everything
you need to know about css positioning
by the time this video is over you'll be
able to position the elements in css
like a pro
so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the ss
position property and its different
types after that we will jump to
practical example to learn how to work
with these properties
so let's get started
so what is css position property
the css position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page
the top right bottom and the left css
position properties
are used to determine the final location
of the element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
webpage
they are static fixed relative and
absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned
you can also use the top bottom left and
right properties to further define the
element's position on a page so let's
discuss each of the properties
individually
css static position
this is a by default position for html
elements
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page
it is not affected by the top bottom
left and right properties
it is important to note that having a
static position is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is css fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's
window and does not move even when you
scroll the window
the next is css relative position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other css properties
we will discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is css absolute position
the absolute positioning is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is html
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties i have the
simple example set up
currently we have three elements with
just basic coloring style
we have not applied any position style
to them
now let's click on this
element too and inspect it
just go to the computed
and type here position to see the
position of this element
so you can see that currently a position
is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is the
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static
if you go here and change the position
to relative
you can see nothing changes
relative act is the same as static with
the only difference is that the relative
allows you to change the top left right
and bottom of this element let me show
you an example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to 20 pixels from the left
let's set the top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixels from the top and even overflows
the element below
this is because relative position when
applied with the top right left and
bottom actually takes that element out
of the document flow
so let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom
so let's make this position to absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by this saving
the absolute value completely removes
the element from the document flow
this is useful when you want a
particular element to be a specific
position we don't want to disturb the
other elements positioning
absolute position positions the element
inside the some parent container that it
can reference
now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if we change the here body position
to relative now the
this nav bar will position the element
according to this body so if we go here
and refresh this
you can see that this 2 is in relation
to with this container
and this is where relative is very
useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top
this is because fixed position elements
are always fixed based on the entire
html element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements
one unique feature of the fixed element
is they stay in the same place when you
scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element two will stay on the same
position
see
the two elements stick to the same
position
but absolute does not work that way when
you change this here to absolute
you can see it does not stay
at the top now
this is one major difference between
absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the cs6 position super easy in this
video
we'll discuss the differences between
both the layouts and we'll discuss which
one you should use
i will also show you
both the layout in a practical example
without diving too deep
so let's first understand the theory
css grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas flexbox is for one-dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating a more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages
whereas the flex items is used to design
the responsive pages without using too
much of positioning or float in our css
code to work with the css grid layout
you have to add grid property to your
element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the display flex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and a flex blocks
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling
here on the page we have a header which
is blue in color
this is the sidebar with a red
background and this is the main content
and this black color is the footer of
the page
here you can see this all these items
are stacked on top of the each other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page uh this is the
main content of the page this is for the
sidebar and this is for the header area
of the page
for the styling part we have used some
basic styling just so as to understand
the example better
now
we can turn the body into a grid by
setting the display property to the grid
so here under the body we'll set the
display to grid
just save the file and refresh
you can see nothing changes because by
default the css grid starts creating
rows automatically and adds the content
in these rows that's why it didn't
change
we can change it by adding the grid
template column property in our body
in our case we'll need two columns one
for sidebar and other for the main
content
let's set the side area to 30
and we'll keep the main area to auto to
cover the remaining spaces
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are broken into the
stills we created
we'll also define the rows for our
header and we'll use the grid template
rows
we'll set the grid template rows for the
header to 60 pixels
for the sidebar and for the main content
we'll set it to auto
and also for the footer we will keep it
60 pixels
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are adjusted in a
2d manner just as we wanted
this shows the power of the grid and the
flexibility it provides to the developer
however
we can see that items are not positioned
properly in the header
and the footer
this is where the flexbox comes into
play as discussed earlier flexbox is
about positioning elements in a
one-dimensional area
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
navigation list class here
and we'll add display as flex
now if you save the file and reload
you can see these are sitting next to
each other
by default the display sets them into
the rows
now we want the contents to be in the
center of the main axis
so we will use the justify content and
set it to center
you can see the items are now in the
center of the main axis
to center them vertically we'll use the
align items and set it to center as well
this will position them in the center
across the axis
for this to work we have to specify the
height so we'll set it to 100 percent
so now you can see the items are aligned
centrally both on the main axis and the
cross axis
let's now add some spacing between these
items
so to give some spacing between we add a
margin to navigation item class
we'll set the margin to 0 for top and
bottom and 10 pixel to left and right
if we save the file and refresh
you can see we have the spaces between
the items
in this video you will learn how to set
a background image on a web page you
will also learn so the basic properties
of the background that are used to set
the image
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
in this tutorial we'll discuss what is
css background image after that we will
discuss some of the basic properties of
the background image in the end we'll
add a background image to our webpage by
adding the code to our text editor
so let's begin by discussing about the
background property of the css
the background image property specifies
an image to use as a background of an
element
the background is defined in the body
element of the html code
to add a background image on an html
element use the html style attribute and
the css background image property and
mention the path of the image inside the
url attribute
there are several properties of the
background that are used to define the
image on a page
some of the common ones are background
image background repeat and background
position
by default the image is repeated so it
covers the entire element
let's switch to the text editor and see
how we can add the background image to
our page so we are on the sublime text
editor let's start by opening a style
tag
the background image is always set on
the body tag so type body and open the
curly braces
the background image is always set on
the body tag so open the body type with
curly braces and start typing background
image
use the url value of the background
image to set the path of the image
make sure the image is in the same
folder as of the html file here we have
our file nature 3.jpg
so mention the path inside the double
quotes
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a web page
as you can see we have the image on the
web page let's format this image a
little bit
we'll start by setting the background
size so type background size
and there are three
values to the background size first one
is auto
it will set the image as it is
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page
as you can see the size of the image is
as same of the original size
the color value will set the image size
that will be fit to the web page
as you can see the image is set to the
whole web page
we can also set the image size to manual
let's say we want the image size of bit
500 pixels so
now as you can see the width of the
image is 500 pixels next we will set the
background repeat property
there are three values to background
repeat first is no repeat with no repeat
value the images will not be repeated on
a page
now as you can see the images are not
repeated
second is repeat x it will set the
images to be repeated on the x axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated on the x x-axis
similarly repeat the images on the
y-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated to the y-axis and there is a
default value repeat which will repeat
the images on the web page
so
let's keep it to cover
so let's keep the background size to
cover
and set the background repeat to no
repeat
let's save the file and look it on our
web page
now as you can see the image is fully
put to the web page
let's add a text above our image to see
how it looks like
so i'll add a paragraph tag
and type some random text here
let's set the text color to red and
align it to center
i'll type p and open the curly braces
i'll set the color to red
and i'll set the text align to center
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
as you can see we have a text above our
image which is centrally aligned and the
text color is red in this tutorial we
will learn how we can add colors to our
page using different methods we will
start with discussing colors and then
see the hex value and rgb format of the
colors
in the end we'll do an example to
understand how we can add colors to our
page
css uses the color values to specify the
colors on a page
they can be specified using predefined
color names hex or rgb format they are
nearly 140 standard color names
hexadecimal is a 60 degree
representation of a color the first two
digits rr represents a red value the
next two are green value and the last is
the blue value
all the other colors can be created
using the combination of these three
colors
there are several websites available
where you can know the hex value of the
different shades of color
as you can see the black color is
signified by hashtag and the six zeroes
the red is hashtag ff and the four zeros
followed by it the rgb color value is
specified using the rgb property this
property takes three values one for red
green and blue the value can be the
integer between zero to 225 or a
percentage
as you can see the black color is
signified by zero zero zero the red by
two fifty five zero zero the blue by
zero zero two fifty five and the green
by zero to fifty five zero
now let's move to an example to
understand how we can add the colors to
our page
in this example we will see how we can
add colors in different ways to our html
so we are on the sublime text editor as
you can see we have the standard wallet
ready with an h2 and a paragraph on our
page open the style tag and make the
font size of the paragraph to 25 pixels
so it is clearly visible
let's start by adding colors to our text
just by color names html supports nearly
140 standard color names
we'll make the color of the paragraph
green for that just type color and set
the color to green
as you can see our paragraph is changed
to green
let's try one more
this time we will add the color red
just refresh
as you can see the color is now changed
to red
there are nearly 140 html standard
colors that are supported by the web
browser
you can also add colors using the rgb
format there are many websites available
to know the rgb or hex value of the
desired color one such is html codes.com
as you can see in the htmlpost.com we
have the hex value and rgb value of the
desired color
let's try one
we'll add this color with rgb value 171
229 and 27 to our paragraph so for that
just type rgb and the color code you
want
as you can see the color is not changed
to our rgb value let's try one more
this time we'll use this rgb value to
our text
you can see the color is changed to our
desired value
in this way you can use the rgb format
to change the colors
the next way is using the hex values
hexadecimal is the sixth representation
of a color the first two digits are red
next one two are green and the last are
the blue value
let's see how you use the hex values
as you can see the hex value for this
color is hash 31787f
we'll use this value to our text
to add the hex value you have to use the
hashtag followed by the color port
you can see that color is changed to a
hex value let's try one more
you can see the hex value for this color
is
f14 a07
copy the desired value to your file
you can see the color changes
you can also add color borders to our
heading
do that just mention the
border style along with the color code
we'll add the border color red to our h2
now you can see we have the border
around our h2
i hope you have understand how to use
the color values to a webpage there are
mainly three ways by which you can add
the colors to your webpage they are
hacks rgb values and the color names
in this video we will discuss what are
keyframes and how you can use them to
add animations to your page
we are going to discuss what are
keyframes and we will try to understand
the syntax of the keyframes so let's get
started
the keyframes are used to specify the
animation code in the page they are used
to change the animation from one pattern
to another
keep in mind that the keyframes do not
have any selectors on them
they are not tested inside anything
they are on the root of the css page you
write at the right keyframes and the
name you can name it anything you want
we are going to use that name later on
to call the selector in this case we are
looking at from and two from implies the
initial state and to the ending state
here in this example the element will
start from 0 pixel and will go all the
way 200 pixel so what we are going to do
right now is we are going to jump to the
keyframes and work out some examples to
understand the working of the keyframes
better so we are on the sublime text
later and this is a simple setup
we have created one html element named
box and we have a css body of padding 50
pixel and the box element is an inline
block
background red with height with 200
pixel
and also i have an animation stat
declared on the box
currently it's doing nothing because it
is calling keyframes called my frames
but we have not yet created any keyframe
we will discuss what this animation line
means at later stage but right now i
need those lines to be able to expose
you to the functioning of the keyframes
you can see we have a box on our page
with the color red
and padding 50 pixels around it
we are going to write add the keyframes
and i am going to use the name my frames
then we'll write prompt condition to
have the starting state and let's just
keep the height 200 pixel
and then we want it to grow and we'll
set it to increase till 500 pixels so
let's just create our keyframes
this is the from condition
we will set it to 200 pixels
and we want it to grow till 500 pixels
just save the file
now as you can see our box is growing
all the way to 500 pixel and when the
animation is done it resets back to 200
pixel and starts again because the
animation is looping you can also put
multiple style declaration for example i
am going to write background pink in the
two condition
just save the file
you can see that the animation is
starting at
red and ending at pink now instead of
saying from and do we can also say from
zero percent to hundred percent
this is as same as doing from and two
but what it enables you to do is you can
add something in the middle of here say
30 and we will make the color any
different
so in the place of prompt we'll write
zero percent
and will replace true with hundred
percent
let's just add one more condition in
between say 40
so at 40 we want the color to change to
say something
uh greed
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so as you can see it starts with red it
turns to green in the middle and then
all the way converts to pink
as you can see there are lots of
interesting things you can do with the
keyframes
all of the things that i am showing you
today are just like how this works
to really get a great understanding of
how it works you just have to open an
editor and start experimenting on it
okay so now let's go back to our code
and learn about animation property
so here we have the animation name my
frames
the animation name should be as same as
keyframes name to work it properly the
animation duration specifies for how
long we want our animation to last in
this case 2 seconds
let's just change this to say
10 seconds
just save the file
now as you can see the
animation is going at a slower speed
just to cover the 10 seconds update
let's just reset it to two seconds
the timing function used to mention the
transition there are some keywords such
as easy and linear easy now and some
more the animation delay is interesting
to understand it means how long we are
going to wait once the animation is
triggered before the visual starts
happening
let's change it to 3 seconds
as you can see the animation starts
after the 3 seconds
iteration count specifies how many times
the animation should happen here we have
set it to infinite
which means animation will keep on going
let's change it to something say 5.
as you can see after the count of five
the animation stops
we'll set it back to infinite
animation running state can be paused or
the running state in this video we are
going to break down everything there is
to know about the css animation
css animations make it possible to
animate transitions from one css style
configuration to another
animations consist of two components a
style describing the css animation and a
set of keyframes that indicates the
start and end states of the animation
style as well as possible intermediate
now to understand this better i have an
example so let's get started now
so we are on our sublime text editor now
to get started i have a very basic
example with html and css
i have a parent element here
and inside this parent element i have a
div class child
so when you go back to the page it will
look something like this
this pink color is the parent element
and the small box with the red color is
a child element
whenever you hover over the element the
child elements move from left side to
the right side of the parent
we want to talk about animation
in case there are two different ways to
animate one is the css transition
property which works well with only
simple animation
if you want to learn about css
translation property you can refer to
the last video on css transition
there is a full-fledged animation
property which is used for more complex
animation
i am going to show you how you can make
this simple transition into animation
for this example we'll make this child
element move all around the box using
animation
so let's go back to our code
so just like the translation property we
have the several properties in the css
animation as well this consists of like
timing function fill-in mode and several
other functions in the css animation
so to convert the transition into
animation all we need to do is write the
word animation and you write the
animation where you want it to happen
in our case here is our hover so we
write the animation here and as you
write you will notice that you have more
properties in animation than transition
in general you will write everything in
this animation keyword because it is
easier you can write it separately as
well like animation delay duration
animation name but
we will use the shorthand property of
the animation
so we'll select the animation
and the first thing the animation needs
is the animation name
so we will give some name to this
animation
say
example
this is just like transition we can
specify our duration
in our case we will use one second
so we have given the
name of the animation
will give the duration we can define our
timing function which will be ease out
this is all the code we need for our
animation
this line is same as writing this
individually
like animation name
[Music]
animation duration one second
and animation timing function
which will be ease out
or let's say even
so for the better understanding let's
just remove the shorthand property and
use the individual properties
now just save the file
let's understand briefly what each of
these properties
do
the animation duration property defines
how long time an animation should take
to complete if the animation duration
property is not specified no animation
will occur because the default value is
0 second
the animation timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
animation
now comes the key frames key frames are
used to define the animation name
we'll come down here and write at the
right keyframes
followed by the name of the animation
the keyframes has to be put outside any
selector
keyframes essentially determine what our
animation looks like between the values
zero percent and hundred percent
so at our animation
we want to have this translate
so
we'll write hundred percent
and we'll write
transform
translate x
100 and save the file
now when you save and go back to the
page
you will notice the smooth transition of
the animation
when you hover over
one thing you will notice that as soon
as the animation is over the box goes
back to the original place
the reason for this is all the process
happens inside this keyframe
this one
as soon as the animation is done the
default state kicks in
if you want this to stop in the
transform state like box should be here
is on the right side
we have to specify it in the animation
property we will set the animation field
mode to forward so here
we'll set the animation fill mode to
forwards
just save
and then when you go back to the
page and refresh
you see the box stops on the right side
and doesn't go back to the original
state
now that you have a basic understanding
of the animation and its different
properties let's work around our main
aim to move this child element all over
the parent element from this to this
side to this side to the side
so
here at the keyframes we just delete
this and we'll start with zero percent
so here at the zero percent
we'll set the transform and translate x
to
zero
after that at 33
we want
this box to move down so we'll work on
translate y
so
we'll translate the y two hundred
percent
at sixty six percent
we want both the x axis and y axis to
to move from here to this side
so
we'll set
translate x 200 percent
and translate
y two hundred percent
and finally at hundred percent
we want to translate x
back to 100
on the upward side
so when you save and refresh
you'll see we have achieved our target
the child elements move all over inside
the parent element
to watch it little bit more slowly let's
change the time here to 3 seconds
when you go back and refresh
you can see the box move little bit
slower
so
with the animation property we can go a
step further we can tell our animation
how many times to repeat the order of
the animation
among other things
so the animation iteration count
property specifies the number of times
an animation should be played
let's set it to 3
so here
we'll set the animation iteration count
to three
the animation direction property defines
whether an animation should be played
forwards backwards or in alternate
cycles
so for the animation direction we set it
to alternate
now if you save and go back
that's one
two
and three after the three count the
animation will stop and you must have
noticed that the box were moving on the
alternate rounds
let's go back to see it again
this is the first cycle now it moves out
on the other direction
and now on the other direction
so this is for animation you can see
animation property is as
same as a transition property with some
more functions and sub properties you
can add more complex animations to the
page with the help of this animation
property
the css transition property is the
simplest way to add the animation to our
website
and in this video we are going to see
how to use it
so animation is a good way to catch
attention on the page and if done
properly it increases the user
experience
the most basic way to animate something
is by transition
according to the mdn definition
transition animals to define the
transition between two states of an
element
basically when the state of an element
changes such as hover focus or anything
else we can change the css property
through a transition
there are handful of transition property
let's discuss what they are and how they
work
so
we are on our port pen
i have a box that changes the color on
the hover
the first property that we are going to
start is with the translation duration
property
the transition division property
specifies how many seconds or
milliseconds a transition effect takes
to complete
so here i can write transition duration
and i can write here a number
take note that here
we can enter time in milliseconds or
seconds
i will suggest to you as you can see
since javascript does not accept time in
second
so i will enter here 500 milliseconds
now
when you go here and hover over this box
you'll see the color changes from pink
to green in about 500 milliseconds
let's
change this to say two seconds
and see the difference
now if you hover this box
you see it takes two seconds to change
the color from pink to green
[Music]
the next one we are going to look is a
transition property the transition
property sets the css properties to
which a transition effect should be
applied
suppose we want to rotate this box when
hovered over
so first we specify the transform
property here and we'll set it to rotate
45 degrees
now here we'll specify the transition
property and set it to transform
now if you hover over this box you see
it takes about 500 milliseconds for the
box to rotate to 45 degrees while the
color changes instantly
suppose we set it here to two seconds
and save
now you will notice the box will take to
about 2 seconds to rotate to 45 degrees
while the color will change instantly
you can see the difference here
now the next property is transition
timing function
the transition timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
transition effect
the default value is ease
ease means it specifies the transition
effect with a slow start and then fast
and then ends slowly
suppose here
we'll set the transition
timing function
to ever
there are four major values for this
timing function they are ease linear
ease in and ease out
let's see one by one in detail
so
the linear function specify the
transition effect with the same speed
from start to end
so if we change here to linear
you will see it rotates with the same
speed from start to end
now if you change this to ease in
the ease it specifies a transition
effect with a slow start so now if you
hover over this
you will see the box rotate the slow
start
and then increases the speed at the end
the ease out specify the transition
effect with a slow end
so if you set it to ease out
you will see at the end the speed
decreases
the last property we are going to
discuss is a transition delay the
transition delay property specifies when
the transition effect will start
the transition delay value is defined in
milliseconds or in seconds
let's set the transition
delay to 2 seconds
and just remove this
now if you hover over this box you will
see it will take two seconds to rotate
the box to 45 degrees
so you can see after the two seconds the
transition property takes place
now if we change here
to background
you see the box will rotate instantly
while the color will changes from pink
to green after 2 seconds
so
this is a translation property
is it as simple as it can be
in this video you will learn how to add
interactive hover effects to your
elements
we will do an example where we will
create hover effects to our buttons
so in this tutorial we will discuss what
is the css hover effects and then we
will do an example to understand it
better
so what is the css over effect a css
hover effect is a style technique where
the user interacts with an element with
a pointing device but it does not
necessarily activates it
it is triggered when the user hovers
over an element with a pointing device
now let's jump to an example
in this example we will create the hover
effects which will look something like
this
we have different hover effects for all
the buttons
so let's get started and see how you can
make this all by yourself
so we are on the sublime text later
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will write our html
and css code respectively
start by linking the css file with the
html file
now we'll add four anchor tags we will
specify the class name for each of them
so that we can style them separately
later
put all the anchor tag inside the div
tag and name the class
middle
we'll name the class btn btn1 btn btn2
btm btmc and btn btn4
just copy paste it four times
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page right now
as you can see we have the pro text on
our page
with this we are done with our html part
now let's shift to css and design the
text and add the hover effects so in css
you will start by setting the margin and
padding to zero we'll also add the
background body color
as you can see the margin and padding is
now zero and we have a good background
color
now we will design the buttons and give
them proper formatting we will start
with the class middle
set the position to absolute
the top property affects the vertical
position of a position element the left
property affects the horizontal position
of a positioned element the transform
property applies a 2d or 3d
transformation to an element this
property allows you to rotate scale and
move the elements
as you can see the elements are now in
place
now let's format the buttons
set the position to relative
display block
we'll keep the color as white
font size 25 pixels
we will use the font family as monty
thread
keep the text decoration to none
we will set the border to true pixel and
solid
we'll keep the text transformation
repeat we'll keep the text
transformation as upper case
transition allows you to change the
property values smoothly over a given
duration
the before selector is used to insert
something before the content of each
selected element
keep the position to absolute
c
we'll keep the transition as all 0.6
second and eve
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
now as you can see all the elements are
in place with proper background and text
we have the padding and border properly
formatted and now we can add the hover
effect to this button
now we'll add the hover effects to the
first button
as you can see we have the hover effect
on our first button ready
in a similar manner we can add the
effects to the second and third button
as well
we'll just copy and paste this above
code below and make changes to this code
we'll set the width to 100 here
and height to zero
we'll change it to height hundred
percent
just save the file and
refresh the page
as you can see both the buttons have the
whole effects now
now it's time to add the hover effect to
our third button
now i will add the hover effect to the
button third
just save the file and go to the page
as you can see all the three buttons are
ready
now it's time to add the hover effect to
the first button
we will set the color to hash ff
this will change the text color to red
when we hover over the fourth button
set the position to absolute
keep the weight as two hundred percent
we'll set the background to hash dcd159
we'll keep the z-index as -1
keep the transition to 0.8 seconds
set the height to 180
percent of the page
now to add the hover effect
print the following code
just save the file
refresh
now you can see we have all the hover
effects on our four button
as you know css animations is a powerful
concept that is used to make your
webpage engaging and attracting visitors
to your website
they make the user experience smooth and
entertaining
so in this video
we are going to learn how to create some
cool css effects using just html and css
so without
further wasting any time let's jump to
our sublime text editor so we are on our
sublime text editor
for our example purpose i have used one
image from an unsplash.com and we have
created a simple class div clock
container for it
now let's go and style these images to
get a 3d effect so first let's design
the body part
we'll set the margin and padding to zero
pixels
we set the width to 100
and we'll set the height to 100 vertical
heights
we'll keep the display as flex
and will align the items in the center
and will justify the content in the
center as well
now we'll design our container class
so for the container class we'll set the
position to relative
we'll set the width to 360 pixels
and we'll keep the height to 640 pixels
we'll set the margin top
to 150 pixels
and we'll keep the
background to white
we'll use the rgba format
we'll use the transform property to
apply a 2d or 3d transformation to an
element
so
we'll use the transform and we'll
use its properties we'll keep this to
30
degrees
we'll set this q to
say 25 degrees
and we'll scale it to 0.8
let's discuss more about these
properties so
the translate property defines a 2d or
3d translation the scale defines the 2d
or 3d scale transformation
and the skew property is used to skew
transformation along the x or y axis
now let's design the images
we'll keep the position to absolute
we'll set the width to 100
and we'll keep the transition time
to 0.5 seconds
let's go back to our page and see how it
looks up to this point
so as you can see we have the images
aligned as we want
on a flat side
now we'll create the 3d transformation
when we hover over it
so let's go back to our css file
so for the 3d effect we are going to use
the edge child property
the n-style selector allows you to take
a single argument that describes the
pattern for the matching element indices
in a list of siblings
we design the each image separately so
for the fourth image
we'll use the transform property and
we'll translate it to 160 pixels and
minus 160 pixels
let's copy this code
four times
okay we have to set the opacity as well
so we'll set the opacity here
to 1.
the opacity property sets the
transparency of the element
just change the number of the nth child
elements so here we keep it to 120
pixels
minus 120 pixel will set the opacity
to 0.8
for the second element let's keep the
translate to 80 pixels
minus 80 pixels and we'll set the
opacity
to say 0.6
and for the last image
we'll translate it to 40 pixels
and minus 40 pixels and we'll keep the
opacity
to say 0.4
so now when you save the file and you
will go back to the page
let's see how it looks
so if you refresh and hover over it
now you can see the image has a 3d over
effect over it
there are four layers to the image and
we have
designed the opacity according to the
image layer
so this is a 3d image hover
the next property we are going to
discuss is a 3d perspective image
so for this let's use a new set of
images
so we'll go back to the unsplash.com
again
and let's select one image
this one looks beautiful
so let's copy the image address
and mention it
under the image tag
just save
[Music]
now when you go back to the page
you'll see you have your image here
now let's add the 3d perspective image
design over it
so under css
file let's first design all the elements
let's keep the margin and padding to
zero
keep the
width of the container elements 200
pixels
or say 100 percent
let's keep the minimum height
to save 100 vertical heights
and we'll use a background color of hash
333
let's design the image as well before
going back to the page
so we'll set the perspective to save
4000 pixels
the perspective property is used to
determine the distance between the z
plane and the user in order to give a 3d
positioned element some perspective
let's keep the width of the image 70
will keep the position to absolute
keep the left margin to 50 percent
and drop to 50 as well
we'll use the transform property
and use that translate value of it to
minus fifty percent and plus fifty
percent
we will use the transform style property
and set the value to preserve 3d
the preset 3d indicates that the
children of the element should be
positioned in the 3d space
so just save the file and let's go back
to the page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see we have the required
background image and we have the image
in our required position
now it's time to style our image
so use the transform property
and we'll rotate
we'll use the rotate x property of it
we'll keep it to 70 degrees
let's discuss this property translate 3d
the translate 3d css functionality
positions an element in the 3d space
it results in the transform function
data type
the transformation is characterized by a
three dimensional vector it coordinates
with how much the element moves in each
direction
let's set the box shadow
to minus 80 pixels
60 pixels
15 pixels
sells an rgba value 2
0 0 0
0.4 let's say
let's set the transition to all point
four seconds
and we'll set the transform style to
preserve 3d
so just save the file and let's go back
to our page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see the image is flat for
and ready for 3d effect
now let's design this 3d hover effect on
it
so for the 3d over effect
we'll use the
cover property image
colon hoover
over the image
we will set the transform
rotate x
0 degrees
rotate thread
to zero degrees
and translate 3d to
zero pixels comma
zero pixel comma zero pixels
let's check this once again
this is right
now we'll set the box shadow to
zero pixels zero pixels zero pixels
zero pixels and rgba
zero comma zero comma zero comma zero
just save the
file and refresh
now when you hover over it you will see
that the perspective of the image
changes
so this is a 3d prospective image
now
there are many css effects that you can
design using these properties
in this video you will learn what is
navigation bar and its importance on a
web page
you will also learn how to create a
basic navbar using html and css
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
we will start with what is navigation
bar and why navigation bar is required
in a web page you will look at some of
the well designed navigation bars on
websites
after that you will work on the code to
create the basic navigation bar using
html and css
so let us begin by discussing what is
navigation
bar a navigation bar is a graphical user
interface intended to aid the user in
accessing the information
it is usually placed at the top of the
page a navigation bar needs standard
html as the base
navigation bars can be created either
vertically or horizontally
so what makes a navigation bar so
important
a navigation bar is an important element
of website design since it allows users
to quickly visit any sections within the
website
if we have ever visited a website
without a navigation bar you may have
found it difficult to locate the page
you need
you may have also had to click back
several times in order to find a link to
the next section you wanted to visit
thankfully web design has become more
standardized in the recent years and
nearly every websites now include a
navigation bar keep in mind that you
want to keep people on your site to
explore further a well-designed
navigation bar is an important part of
the user experience now let us look at
an example of a navigation bar on our
website
we are on the homepage of amazon website
as you can see this is the navigation
bar that has several elements on it
as the user clicks on these elements
they will be directed to the different
sections of the website the navigation
bar allows the user to easily move
through any section of the website
by clicking on the best sellers button
you will be redirected to the best
sellers page on the amazon
now we are going to create a navigation
bar with html in css that's going to
look like this we'll have the following
sections with sub menus and some of them
make sure you have a text editor to
write the code
i'll be using a sublime text later for
this purpose we will create two new
files index.html and style.css where we
will be writing on html and css code
respectively
let's start by adding the standard wall
update
keep the title as css nav bar
link your css file with the html file by
using the link tag and htf attribute
this navigation bar is going to consist
of a bunch of ul tags which means an
another list and list items let's create
our first another list and this will be
our main menu of the navigation bar
i have options such as home about
contact services and news so this is
going to be our main menu
save the file let's see what it looks
like right now by opening it inside our
browser
you can see it is just an unordered list
with no menu at this point let's go
ahead and add our sub menus home will
not have any sub menus but the about
list item is going to have a sub menu
add another ui tag inside the ally tag
this will create a sub menu inside the
about item save the file
just copy paste it and paste it inside
the ul tag
name them as team
clients
careers and legacy
just make the indentation properly
if you see this in a browser you will
see that we'll have
the sub menus inside the above let's do
the same thing for contacts just copy
paste this whole section and place them
inside the contacts list rename them
according to your wish and save the file
if you go back to the browser
you will see that we'll have the
submenus inside the contacts as well
as you can see this is our complete
submenus without the styling all the
html content is ready now we are going
to write the css for it in the css file
let's apply the background image first
because it will make the page look a
little bit nicer
i have my file on my computer make sure
the image file is in the same folder as
your html and css file
i am using a tech.jpg
and for the background size i will set
it to the cover which is going to adjust
it to the image screen and it's going to
cover the whole background of our web
browser
keep the font family as arial
let's see what it looks like at this
stage you can see we have a background
image and the font is changed to arial
now let's make sure our unordered list
does not have any margins or padding by
setting it to zero
also put the list style to then because
we don't want to have any kind of
bullets under our listing
now unordered list list items they are
the main items that are going to apply
the style to the list items of the main
url tag
float that all the text to the left
and set the given formatting
we will set the background color with
the hash value 003542
you can choose your own value from our
website known as colorpicker.com
we will fix the line height to 40 pixels
this will center the text vertically
text align to center
this will align the text horizontally
and font size to 20 pixel
font size 20 pixels
let's see what it looks like now you can
see the text is floated to the left
now let's tell the actual menu link so
the menu link will be ullia
uli a
keep the text decoration
to none and color white
keep the display as block
now it's time to set the hover effect of
our array the ui alloy hover will set
the formatting when the user hovers over
the menu
we will use the background color of the
hash value de1 fcb
save the file and let's see what our
page looks like up to this point
you can see we have the hover effect
over our menus and we have the sub menus
under the main menu we want our sub menu
should be visible only when we hover our
menus so we'll set the uli to display
none and we'll set the hover effect to
the block
um
let's save the file and see what our
page looks like up to this point
now you can see
our navigation bar is ready
with all the submenus and menus at
proper places we have this nice over
effect over the menus
in this video we will discuss some cool
tricks that every web developer should
be familiar with and which will help you
during the time of your designing of a
webpage so let's jump onto the sublime
text editor and see these tricks so
the first trick is called the css blend
mode the css background blend property
sets the blend mode for each background
layer and you can blend it with image or
with different colors with the help of
this property we can blend background
image or blend them with colors
so
here's an example of the css blend mode
here you can see the images are blended
with different colors
so let's see how we can achieve this
so for our example purpose i am going to
use this image
to our page
so in the body tag add the image url
and the location of a file
keep the margin left and margin right to
auto
now let's add some style to a body tag
in the blend mode there are several
modes such as normal multiply darker and
lighter or screen
let's blend that image with one color
so you can select the color from the
html color codes
i'll use this color for my purpose
so just copy paste here
and in the background blend mode let's
keep it to lighten
now if you save
and then refresh here
you can see we have blended our image
with color
let's go back and change here something
different
let's keep it to darken
let's try something different
let's keep it to screen
so as you can see there are several
properties for this blend mode and you
can use according to your needs the next
trick is called clipping the css
clipboard property creates a clipping
region that specifies the region that
should be shown on the page
so let's understand this with the help
of an example here we'll create a div
and give this class any class say tr
the easiest way to generate the clip
value is to use a generator
there are several websites that give the
value of the clip
so we'll use this
website to generate a clip value
suppose we want a hexagon shaped image
on our page
so here you can
adjust it according to your needs
any shape that you want
here you can see the clip value just
copy paste it from here
now here we'll use that class that we
have specified
we'll just copy paste the clip value
here
we will keep the height to say
50
or let's say 60
set the width to 60 as well
select the color you want to give to a
clipped image
i'll use the same color from the
previous example
so just copy paste this color code
keep the position to absolute
and the z index to minus 1
just save and go back to the page and
refresh
now you can see we have the clipped
image on our page let's try something
different
um let's say i want
a left arrow
so just copy paste this
clip
value clip path value
[Music]
just save the file
and you can see we have the arrow on our
page
another must have for web developers is
animations
css allows us to animate almost every
property that we use in the css
let's look at one example
so here an html file will just add one
div tag first
and to start with animation we'll have
to mention a keyframe the keyframes
allows us to create different steps for
our animations
we'll keep the keyframes name to blink
so here in this example we'll create a
box and we'll add different colors at
different points of animations right so
we'll write zero percent and we'll set
the background
to indigo
we'll change the colors five times so
just copy paste this code five times
we want next change at 30 so we'll set
the background here
suppose say red
at 50 we wanted yellow
at 70 we wanted green
and finally we'll change it to say blue
so inside the div tag we'll mention the
height and width of the box first let's
say 400 pixels and width also 400 pixels
now we'll mention the
border of the box so just set it to say
one
pixel solid black
now for the animations part
will set the animation for 10 seconds
and for infinite number of times
write this webkit so as to support in a
google chrome
now just save the file and go back to
our page
and here you can see we have the
animation on our box
you can style each and every element in
html using animations
another thing you can do is add pss
gradient
the css gradient property allows you to
add smooth transitions between two or
more colors
for this purpose you can get the
gradient value from a website called
grid css gradient dot io
here in this website
you can get the mix and match of the
different colors you want to use
let's look at one example to understand
better
so here in this html file first let's
set the height
so we'll set the height to hundred
percent
now inside the body tag
we'll keep the height as hundred percent
will mention when background color
let's select different color this time
so we will use save this color
this
time just copy paste the value here
now for the gradient value just go back
here in this website and you can select
the color you want
let's say i want a mix of this color
and
you can change the shades from here
now when you're done with the colors
just go back below and copy this
code here
to your page
now when you go back to the page you'll
have a beautiful gradient here
let's try one more
this time a linear gradient
just copy this value to your code
just save the file and go back to the
page
and you will have a linear gradient here
in this video we are going to learn some
of the more advanced features that can
be used to optimize your web page and
add some extra features to it
so let's get started so the first
function we are going to discuss is css
sudo class
a css sudo class is a keyword added to a
selector that specify the special state
of the selected elements
sudo class lets you apply a style to an
element not only in relation to the
content of the documentary but also the
relation to external factors like
history of the navigator the status of
it content or the position of the mouse
like hover which lets you know if the
mouse is over an element or not
so the first sudo class we are going to
discuss is css hover
this pseudo class is used to add a
special effect to an element when our
mouse pointer is over it
let's work an example to understand how
this works
so we are on our sublime text editor and
we have added a standard wall update to
it
so first i'll create a box element
we get the div class box
let's save this and see right now what
is the status of our page
so as you can see we have this
simply learn tag and the heading that we
have given that the color changes when
you hover over me
now add a style tag to define the
styling of the box
so
we'll keep the background color of the
box as
keep the width to 300 pixels
and height
to 200 pixels
we'll set the margin to auto
let's keep the font size to 40 pixels so
that we can see the text clearly
and we'll align the text to the center
just save and go back to the page
now you can see
we have this box with the tag the color
changes when you hover over me
now to add the hover effect
you just have to mention the class with
semicolon and hover so we'll mention the
class box
with a semicolon and hover
will mention the background color to
which the box will change when you hover
over a mouse
so we will keep the background color to
say a cn color
just save and go back to the page
so if you refresh and when you hover
over it you can see the color changes
so
this is how the pseudo hover class works
the next photo class we are going to
discuss is an active pseudo class
the active pseudo class represents an
element that has been activated by the
user either by pointing a device or by a
touchscreen device
let's work on an example to understand
how to use the active class to change
the color of active elements the
possible values could be any color name
in any valid format
so we'll use the same example with some
minor changes
first
let's change this text here
we'll keep it to click here
to see the effects
we keep this part as same and instead of
over air we will use the active pseudo
class so
we type active and we'll keep the
background clear to cyan
let's text align this h1 to the center
when you refresh and go back
so
you see here it is click here to see the
effects now
to see the difference now you can see
when we are hovering over it the color
does not change it instead of it when we
click on it the color changes
so
this is how the active hover class works
the next advanced property we are going
to discuss is a css pseudo-element
css pseudo element is a keyword added to
a selector that lets you style a
specific part of the selected element
you can use one sudo class element in a
selector
it must appear after the simple
selectors in the statement
as a rule double column should be used
instead of a single column this
distinguishes the pseudo classes from
the pseudo element so the first pseudo
element we are going to discuss is the
first letter pseudo element this pseudo
element applies tie to the first letter
of the first line of the block level
element
let's work out an example to understand
this better
just delete everything
so let's add some content to the body
and we'll add an h1
which says welcome
to simply learn
and we'll add an h2 which says
this is an example
of
first
letter
pseudo element
let's add a style tag
we
align the text in the body to the center
so we'll use text align
center
let's just give proper spacing here
now to this h1
tag we'll add the first letter sudo so
to add the first letter sudo element
just use the double colon and type first
letter
we'll keep the font family of the first
leicester assay lucida
calligraphy
there's a spelling mistake
we will keep the font size to three
centimeters
we'll keep the color to red
and just add a text shadow
for better animation
so we'll keep the text shadow to 5
pixels
keep pixels
and pixels and color cn
now when you save and go back
just refresh so this wc is a first
letter sudo element
as you can see we have changed this
first letter with the proper shadowing
of a cn color and a different font size
so this is how the first letters
pseudo element works
the next one we are going to discuss the
before sudo element
the before sudo element can be used to
insert some content before the content
of an element
let's work out an example
so just add the standard wallet plate
inside the body
let's
add welcome to simply learn
we'll add the text inside the queue tag
the q tag defines a short quotation so
inside the queue tag
we'll add welcome
simply learn
now that we have the text inside the
body let's add the styling
so we'll keep the font size of all the
text 230 pixels
this is the all selector we have used
font size 30 pixels
now before the text we are going to add
some symbols so we will use double
column queue before
we add the content with sun symbol like
this
we'll keep the color of this
symbol to blue
and we'll use the after sudo class to
add the content
like this
we'll keep this color to red
now that we have everything in place
let's go back to see how it looks
you can see the symbols before and after
our text so this is how the before
studio element works
so the next function we are going to
discuss is css loader
the css loader is an animation that
shows the wizard about the page when it
is loading
it is helpful when a page takes some
seconds to load the page content it is
similar to the buffer sign so let's see
how to create a
loader so i hope you remember the
concept of the keyframes and animations
if you want to revise the concepts you
can watch the previous videos on the
keyframes and animations from the
playlist
so
let's create the loader
we have the standard wall applied
so inside the body tag
just add the center tag and inside it
will add one h1 which says
welcome to simply learn
we'll add
five div tags with the class a1 a2 a3 a4
and a5
just copy paste it 5 times
so this is a1 a2
a3 a4
and a5
let's open our style tag
inside our style tag we'll first add
color to our h1
so
let's keep the color of our h1 to orange
now comes the div tag
so for the div tags
we'll keep the display to block
uh keep the position to absolute
we set the width and height to 10 pixels
each so width 10 pixels
and height 10 pixels
we'll use the cat function to determine
the left margin
so to use the calc function that add
calc
50
and minus 1 em
the calc function performs a calculation
to be used as a property value
we'll keep the border radius to say 1.3
em
em is related to the font size of the
element
1.3 em means 1.3 times the size of the
current font
we'll use the transform origin function
with the value 1.3 em
and 2 here
the transformation property allows you
to change the position of the
transformed elements
2d transformations can change the x and
y axis
to keep the animation
to rotate
i will keep the animation iteration
count
infinite
and we'll keep the animation duration to
two seconds
let's save and go back to the page to
see how it looks at this point
so as you can see we have our heading
and
you cannot see it but we have a loader
ready
and we just have to add some keyframes
and animations here
so
let's define keyframes
with the name of the animation rotate
so at zero percent
we use a transform
function to rotate it to
zero degrees
just copy copy this
at hundred percent when it's complete
it'll rotate to the complete 360 degrees
so here we give the value 360 degrees
now let's design each of the
classes here that we have defined
so
dot a1
the animation delay
will be of 0.1 seconds
so for each of the classes that we have
here we have to define them with a
different color
so that when the loader appears we can
see them clearly with the different
colors so
for this
a1 let's keep the background color to
say san
just copy paste it
so that we don't have to write down code
again and again
three four and five
let's make changes here
so for the a2
we want it
to appear after 0.2 seconds
with the color pink
let's keep this to 0.3 seconds
the color purple
0.5 seconds let's color black
we have kept the animation delay to so
close like 0.1 seconds 0.2 seconds 0.3
seconds so that the
loader appears in a complete sync with
each other
so just save the file and refresh and go
back to the page
now you can see this is the loader we
have our heading and
this is like a buffer
and it will show when you have some
content to load
in this tutorial we are going to discuss
what is concept design and how we can
achieve this using the css media query
so let's get started making a website
with an adaptable layout is called
responsive web design and css media quiz
are one of the most important part of
responsive design
in the past building a website was much
simpler today a website layout should
adapt itself not only to computers but
also to tablets mobile devices and even
tvs
so
let's see how we can create responsive
web layout using css media keys within
help of an example so here we are on our
sublime text editor we have used our
standard wallet ready so let's create
something
so let's start by creating the four days
here
we'll give it a class name box
with an id box one
we'll name this windows
just copy it four times
let's rename this id to box 2 and here
we'll type mac os
for the box 3 will have
linux and the box 4 will have android
let's add some styling over here
so just open the style tag
i will text align the text we'll send
the text align to center
uh we'll set the background color
let's select some color
so we go to this html color code choose
a good color
you set the text color to white
and we'll set the font size to say
something to the pixels
and just save the file let's go back to
refresh the page
let's figure it out
okay so first this is not valid
so after you refresh you see we have our
lives with windows mac os linux and
android and with this background color
so
to design the responsive web pages use
the media queries
so what are media queries let's first
discuss this
so a media queries are used when you
want to customize the website's
presentation according to the user's
screen type with the help of the media
queries you can display different
markups based on the device's general
type mobile desktop tablet you name it
a media code is a logical operation
whenever a media query becomes true then
the related css is applied to the target
element
so
to start the media query just type at
the rate
and media
now here we'll mention the max weight
to save 400 pixels
and inside this media query we write the
css code that should
take an effect when this condition is
satisfied
so here
we'll set the box 1
[Music]
to display block
now
if you go back to the page and you
refresh
you see nothing happens because we have
not made this display to none so first
go back to the css code
and set hit display to none
now you can see we don't have any
display here so let's inspect the page
first
so you will see we have our contents
here
now you can see this is the
layout we are currently using the
current width is 685 pixels into height
255 pixels
now we are setting the max width to 400
pixels this means if this bit decreases
to less than 400 pixels how this css
code will kick in so let's decrease the
width here
so as you decrease
this width
you see as soon as you get less than 400
pixels our css kicks in so we have our
windows displayed here which is the box
id1 so this is how the media query works
let's add some more media queries to
understand it better so just copy this
code down
so now let's set this minimum width
to
401 pixels
and maximum to say 600 pixels
now when this condition is true let's
say we want our box to
to display block
with color
green
so let's set the background color here
to let's
say green
now
we'll add one more media query
so just copy this code
paste it here
so when the bit is from 601 pixels to
say
800 pixels
so we'll set the box 3 display
to block and color
to
clicking
so
just save this and let's understand it
on the page
so
let's
change the width of the screen
so see as soon as the width goes less
than 400 pixels we have our windows on
display
now when we increase the width size and
it goes more than 401 pixels we have the
mac os display
keep on increasing it
now see the width is more than 600
pixels and we have linux on display so
this is how we create the responsive web
design for the different devices
hello everyone and welcome you all so
today is very exciting day because today
we're gonna talk about something
very interesting which is related to
your css interview questions
as we know it very well today in a
current scenario
you being as a front-end developer
css playing a very very important role
so in interview what kind of questions
are asked and what kind of answers we
have to give let's talk about those
okay so let's get started with those
questions and answers
okay
now
here
we'll talk about basic css interview
questions
now name some css frameworks as we know
it very well today in css environment
there are so many frameworks are
available
okay like
we talk about css these are basically
necessary libraries which offers you
some very popular ready-made components
which you can utilize into your
existing project and without writing
much code you can really create some
awesome effects so
some of the very very popular libraries
are like in foundation
bootstrap
gumby
ukit symantec ui
and many more which are available here
okay
now what do you understand by the
universal selector see universal
selector as you know it very well in css
normally we talk about specific
selectors like in talk about class
selectors id selectors
they select a specific set of elements
or a specific element
when we talk about universal selectors
universe selector is matches any element
types like instead of selecting elements
of a particular type so you talk about
like an asterisk where the all elements
irrespective of what name and what
category they have it all will be
selected
next tell us about
rule set see typically rule set is
for the identification for selector
which can be attached with
other selectors so there are normally
two rule sets are available
when we talk about declaration block and
we talk about selector
so declaration block contains one or
more semicolons separated by
declarations set of styles which we say
and the selector is means or which
particular element this css style will
be
intended for
next
what are the elements of css box model
okay so we know it very well the csx box
model is all about offering you the
layout
which is a part of the design element so
in css we can see this elements are like
in images we talk about text okay we
talk about padding which is so called
area around the content you talk about
border talk about margin
okay so you talk about this css box
model
next
difference between css3 and css2 we know
it very well css has changed a lot and
css3 has brought so many new features
so we talk about a difference so in css2
so c6 splits up the different sections
of code into the modules so in css3 both
css and html were put into the single
file
in css3 there were no new way of writing
the css rules
there are new rules are available
in writing a css rules
normally in css3 it is a backward
compatibility maintained by the css3
but in css2 we do not have any backup
compatibility maintained by the css2
here
now how can css be
integrated into the html page
like in order to utilize this we always
use the style sheet we use style tag
okay so multiple options are available
when we talk about using the style tag
in a head section
else we talk about inline styling with
an element itself or third we talk about
external style sheet which you can link
it with your current html page which
anyways enforce reusability
coming back what is the rgb stream
so rgb stands for red green and blue so
it represents a color in css so they are
basically uh starting with the color
number 0 goes till 256.
next
what is the purpose of developing a css
okay the main purpose of developing a
css to basically offer the visual
appearance to give the better look and
feel to your code so that your html will
offer only the skeleton part but when it
comes to the beautification
you talk about organization and
everything you talk about the css
okay so css offers the styling part of
your web page which looks more
attractive
so what is the difference between class
and id see these are two different type
of selectors are available in css
class selectors and id selectors so
class is the way of using these html
elements
so they are not unique and have multiple
elements
where the id is unique and it can be
assigned to a single element
so with css different documents can be
controlled using the single style so
style can be grouped in a complex
situation
to offer the consistent
look for the multiple html pages
so that is what the advantage is you
have it
so you can group multiple styles
together and that you can reuse over the
different pages to offer the consistent
styling
okay
now we talk about some intermediate css
interview questions
so here in the intermediate level you
will see
like the first question is like what
define a z index see zen index is
specify the stack order of the elements
that overlap each other
okay so its default value is zero and
can take both negative and positive
values
okay
the higher the z index value is stacked
above the lower index element so it
normally takes the following value
talk about like an auto number initial
and inherit
next
you talk about what are the benefits of
css sprite see the main benefit of css
sprite is
like loading a multiple image is not
an issue
okay
uh blinking is not seen there are some
advantages are available like when you
talk about like
at one single or small small images
it really takes a lot of time to
download it individually so css sprites
loading multiple image is not an issue
blinking is not seen
because normally what happens blinking
happens when the image is getting loaded
so advanced downloading of asset doesn't
make a place off
until needed that's the benefit of
having the css sprites
next how can you target the h3 and h2
with the same styling so you can do the
comma separated so you can see multiple
elements can be targeted with using
comma separated so you use comma
separated values to give the consistent
style to both elements
so name and media types allowed by css
so media types are basically a part of
your responsiveness
different media types are allowed like
in speech audio visual
tactile media continuous or page media
grip media or bitmap or interactive
media
these are all type of medias
are allowed in css
so how can you use
css to control image repetition so we
talk about no repeat
so background repeat properties which is
available so you can see
background repeat none so that it would
not be repeated again and again within
your background
okay so we're talking about the next
questions like
about the image scrolling control how
you can
control the image scrolling so that you
want the image to be remain fixed
and rest of the part gets scrolled
so here it is a part of your background
attachment property
so here you say the background repeat no
repeat and you see background attachment
fixed so that when you scroll down your
image is not going to be scrolled
so that is the benefit of this image
control scrolling
now
name some font related css attributes
we have some options available like you
talk about font style weight
variance size
family these are the
font related css attributes
define contextual selector
so normally in css the contact
contextual selectors allows developer to
specify style of a different part of the
document
okay so style which you utilize it can
be aligned directly to the static html
pages
to create independent classes
okay that's called contextual selector
so responsive web design responsive web
design is a web design which you want to
remain consistent
across multiple device screens or the
different type of screen sizes and you
want to offer the better layout which
doesn't looks bloated over the different
websites
so that's the benefit which you see when
you talk about like responsive web
design
this is
nomenclature
css nomenclature means the styling
commands are written in a value on a
property fashion
okay so normally css includes a system
terminator semicolon the entire style is
wrapped in a curly braces and attached
to the dedicated selector
okay so this actually creates a style
sheet that can be applied to an html
page so this is the standard
nomenclature
okay
now coming back to the next point
advanced css interviews
i will tell you about few questions
which are normally asked as a part of
advanced css
okay now when do you use translate
instead of absolute positioning okay so
the translate in a css
okay transform value on changing you can
talk about opacity or transform
okay so the browser reflow or repaint is
not triggered
when you talk about this translate
okay so the transform requires a browser
to create a gpu layer for
elements
okay but using the cpu changes
absolute positioning property so
translate is more efficient and result
in
shorter paint times
next name different ways to position
same aspects in css
okay
so you talk about positioning properties
okay
so there are five different positions
values are number one you talk about
fixed we talk about static
you have absolute you have got relative
and never got sticky so five different
positioning elements are available in
css
what are mixins
mixins is a similar to the function
block of code returning a single value
it is a kind of function which we say
okay
so traditionally it is used in a sas or
okay which is typically called
statically awesome style sheet so
that code that directly compiles into
the css styles
so how can you optimize the web page for
the prints so
you actually identify a control
okay so-called contents areas of a
website
a general website has a footer header
sidebar or nav bar
or
content area
so normally we say conquer the print
media without changing the website's
integrity by using the page breaks so
creating styles for print
size
your page for print and avoid
unnecessary html tables so using this
you can optimize the print of your web
pages
so what is the meant by css working
under the hood so when you browser
display a document it actually combine
the style
okay which presents information and
document content so the document is
actually processed in two stages number
one
conversation
okay or conversion of html and css into
the document object model so called dom
and dom display contents of browser
different between the use of id selector
and class selector we have already seen
that but this is a simple demo of how
the id selector in class selectors are
used the difference is all about using
so here you have a call id which you use
dot sorry this hash and there you use
dot
so tell us about css float property so
normally css float properties
uh of positioning an image to the right
or left as needed so it typically
including text wrapping around it so all
properties of elements used before it
remain unchanged that is known as called
float
so what you understand with the pseudo
elements so pseudo elements are special
effects to your selectors so normally
css finds
okay using applying styles in a html
markup so if additional markup or style
is not visible for a document then
pseudoelements help by allowing extra
markup without
interfering with the original
document
different between
logical and physical tag so normally
logical tags focus on the content
okay
and are older as compared to the
physical ones
logical ones do not find much usage in
presentation in terms of
utilization at the same time physical
ones find application in presentations
so how media type works in css type so
we have discussed already about a media
type
so we normally say four different type
of media properties are available i can
print speech and screens
okay like you talk about
print media screen so we use always add
the rate media print you talk about h2
so this changes according to what option
you're offering it
so guys here we have multiple css
question and frequently our css
interview questions are offered like
tell
something about css3
okay so we say css is divided into the
modules and is supported by almost every
single browser
okay it is an advanced version of css2
and offering you lot many other advanced
level features which typically in css2
we do not have that
okay
now
we talk about how css selectors used
so with the css selectors we can choose
you know any element of your html okay
so
you talk about element attribute you
talk about n child selector you can
basically select it
so what are css image scripts
so the group of image placed into the
one single image is in a css image
script it can reduce the load time
because individual images certainly take
more time so this takes more time
comparatively
so we have a god explain css
a specificity
so the css specificity is a rank or
score that decides style declarations to
be used to an element
id selectors have high specificity while
universal selector has low specificity
that's how the specificity is all about
so the four css categories that
authorize the selectors is specificity
levels are ids inline element sudo and
class and style attributes
so these are the different type of
conditions based on that the specificity
is considered
defined gradients in css we know the
gradient
are
again a css3 property that allows
displaying the smooth transformation
from one type of color to another color
okay
so that's really awesome technique
through which you can talk about linear
gradient or else you talk about radian
gradients small two different type of
gradients are
used and supported
so what are the properties of flexbox so
we know it flexbox are basically
designed for the alignment purpose
so typical the flexboxes are flex
direction you talk about wrap flow
content align items and the contents
like that it is once again the property
of alignment
so tell us about the usage of css box
model
so normally blocks box model is a box
binding
in html elements that includes padding
border margin and the actual contents
for the more better alignment
so normally the box model you get an
authority to add a border all around the
elements and define space between the
elements
so what are the position states in css
so we'd normally talk about four
positions in css so called relative
statics absolute and fixed
the default position is status always
static
so different between absolute and
relative in css
so normally relative is useful for some
tags in css if we write like 20 pixels
then padding shift 20 pixels in a right
but when we talk about absolute
so it is
absolute is relevant relative to the
non-static pattern that means if i'm
talking about
if we say right 20 pixels the result
will be 20 pixels far from the right
edge of the parent element
that's how the relative and absolute
position is
so what is the common between class and
id see both class are id used in html
okay for the css purpose the id is used
as an element where the class is used as
a block so thank you all for watching
this session on html and css glucose we
hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions feel free to put them in the
comment section on this video thank you
again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you